ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING WE ARE
CONTINUING TO PRACTICE THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THE MASS BE WARNED AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM OR AT A
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE WILL
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
A BILL PLEASE LISTEN FOR MY
PROP TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN ALL TIMES.
WE'RE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AS WELL AS YOUR TELEPHONE
TELEVISION SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO WHEN
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON BEGIN STEP.
OPERATOR ON THE LINE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE SAFE
IF YOU. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
THESE LITTLE LABELS BACKGROUND
MUSIC.
THERE'S BEEN A COUPLE OF
THE PUBLIC REALM IMPROVEMENTS
OKAY. NOW LET'S TALK WITH
GROUND RULES FOR APPROPRIATE
HONDA. ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED
A NUMBER OF DESTRUCTION AND
FORMER. THIS OR OTHERWISE. YEAH
OKAY THAT IS. THE ONE THAT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING ABOUT BAD.
WHAT. ALL THE TIME A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE. THE BILL. THAT
WOULD BE GREAT I DON'T. RIGHT
AWAY UNDERNEATH TO REMEMBER. I
WILL TAKE THE CALLS. IF
INDIVIDUAL DOES. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE RENT BOB AND WARNED OF
THE THANK YOU FOR MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL WE HAVE TO BUILD A
WATER. BOTTLE NOT OKAY
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED FROM
DISRUPTIVE. ARE GREAT. STUFF IN
THERE. AND YEAH IS NOT SO
FEDERAL REPUBLIC YOU IS THAT TO
THE PHARMACY FOR A- INDIVIDUAL
THE HELP WILL GO. WE HAVE BEEN.
LOGGED IN OF THE DAY. SIX THOSE
ITEMS ARE PER FOR CAN. ITEMS
EIGHT NINE AND- SB EIGHT TEN
IT'LL EIGHT TWELVE BY THE
GOVERNOR FIND COMMITTEE. I AM
TWELVE SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR LAP LEARN. I AM
THIRTEEN SB SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR NIELSEN. I AM FOURTEEN
S. B. FOR THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR
RUBIO. WE ALSO HAVE A SPECIAL
ORDER OF BUSINESS TODAY WE'LL
BE HEARING ITEM ONE SB FIVE
FIVE SIX BY SENATOR DODD FIRST
WE WILL THEN MOVE ON TO ITEM
TWO SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. AFTER RE
DISPENSED WITH THE SPECIAL
ORDERED WE WILL HEAR BILLS IN
THE ORDER SHOWN ON THE AGENDA
OTHER WHAT- UNLESS OTHERWISE
NOTED. IN ADDITION SB NINE BY
SENATOR ATKINS WILL BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR MCGUIRE.
WE WILL TAKE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
FOR EACH BILL. THESE WITNESSES
WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY. WE DO
HAVE ONE EXCEPTION SB FIVE FIVE
SIX WE WILL HAVE THREE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION EACH OF
WHOM WILL ONLY HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO PRESENT THEIR TESTIMONY EACH.
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. WE ARE ALSO
LIMITING TIME FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES TO A TOTAL
OF FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE
THIS MEANS WE'LL TAKE CALLS
FROM ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES THEN MOVE ON
AND TAKE THE CALLS FOR
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES. IF YOU ARE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY WITHIN THIS FIFTEEN
MINUTE PERIOD PLEASE SUBMIT
REST WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. LET'S
SEE- WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
OKAY- WE WILL OPERATE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM.
OUR FIRST BILL IS ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. B. FIVE FIVE SIX BY
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SB FIVE FIVE SIX
WOULD BRING CALIFORNIA INTO
CONFORMANCE WITH THE EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW SEEKING
TO ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
WIRELESS BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. DEMAND FOR RELIABLE
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY HAS NEVER BEEN
HIGHER THAN IT IS TODAY THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
CLEARLY ELEVATED OUR
UNDERSTANDING THE BROADBAND
ACCESS IS ESSENTIAL FOR
PARTICIPATING IN EVERY ASPECT
OF MODERN SOCIETY. SB FIVE FIVE
SIX WILL ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM
BY CONFORMING WITH CALIFORNIA
LAW WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FCC FEDERAL REGULATION
IN ORDER TO EXPAND FIVE G.
DEPLOYMENT THEY CONTRIBUTE TO
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES LOCALITIES
TO GIVE ACCESS TO THEIR STREET
LIGHTING TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLES
IN ORDER FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES TO ATTACH THEIR
WIRELESS FACILITIES. THE BILL
FOCUSES ON ENSURING THAT ACCESS
TO THESE POLLS IS PROVIDED AT A
NON DISCRIMINATORY COST BASED
RATES. THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SKEWS ME HOWEVER MANY
LOCALITIES THROUGHOUT THE AREA
ARE INTERPRETING- IT'S- LET ME
START OVER OKAY YEAH SB FIVE
FIVE SIX WILL CREATE UNIFORMITY
WITH THE FCC ORDER BY FIRST
OFFERING FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE OPTION TO CONFORM TO THE
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DOLLAR FCC
PRESUMPTIVE RATE. THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHO DO NOT WISH TO APPLY THE
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DOLLAR RATE
THE OPTION TO USE THE COST
BASED ATTACHMENT RATE FORMULA
IS MODELED AFTER THE E. B. TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. THAT COST
BEFORE IN THIS BEEN USED IN
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES FOR
YEARS AND IT'S BEEN APPLIED BY
THE CPUC TO INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AND TELEPHONE
COMPANIES AS WELL- GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS ARE CONTINUING
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR A
COMMITMENT. TO ADVANCE EQUITY
AND I ALSO WANT TO ASSURE
MEMBERS THAT I WILL BE TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE BACKS
COMMITTEE TO REPORT. TO ADD
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT
THE STATE GOALS FOR UNIVERSAL
BROADBAND ACCESS ARE BEING MET.
ON THE PHONE IS BARBARA NEMCO
FOR NAPA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN THE HEARING ROOM
FOR SUPPORT IS RUDY RADIUS-
FROM VERIZON. DATE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR- WEIRD OPERATOR PLEASE
ADD MISSED THEM CO. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
AFTERNOON ON BARBARA. HI I'M
BARBARA NEMCO I'VE BEEN THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND NAPA FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND AN EDUCATOR FOR
MORE THAN FIFTY. DURING ALL OF
THIS TIME WE HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO
IT DESPITE EXPENDITURES OF
LARGE SUMS OF MONEY AND A PART
OF THE REASON IS WE HAVE NOT
HAD THE DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY TO
DO IT WHY IS DIGITAL SO
ESSENTIAL WHY IS THAT ESSENTIAL
THAT EVERY CHILD HAVE BROADBAND
ACCESS. KIDS TODAY CAN'T DO
THEIR HOMEWORK WITHOUT THAT TO
WE SEE CHILDREN SITTING OUTSIDE
SCHOOLS AND OUTSIDE STARBUCKS
SO THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO GET
ONLINE. USING DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGY WE CAN DO MORE THAN
JUST CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
WE CAN ACCELERATE AND THEN RICH
TREATMENT BECAUSE IT GIVES US
THE OPTION. OF HAVING CHILDREN
LEARN IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS WE
PERSONALIZE IT YOU CAN LEARN
THE SKILLS OF MASKED BY DOING
SOMETHING THAT IS MEANINGFUL TO
YOU AND THAT PERHAPS A CAREER
AREA THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
BECAUSE YOU CAN DO IT ONLINE.
ONE FEATURING FRONT OF A
CLASSROOM CANNOT PERSONALIZED
FOR EVERY CHILD IN THE CLASS
BUT DIGITAL ALLOWS US TO DO IT
IT IS ALSO MUCH MORE ENGAGING
THAN ANY BOOK OR ANY PETER
COULD EVER BE. BECAUSE IT
RESPONDS THAT YOU ANSWER AND
YOU GET FEEDBACK IMMEDIATELY
THE TEACHER CAN'T GIVE FEEDBACK
IMMEDIATELY TO EVERY CHILD IN
THE ROOM BUT THE COMPUTER CAN
FOR WHICH I WAS WORKING ON
SOMETHING HE'S INTERESTED IN
HE'S GETTING IMMEDIATE
FEEDBACK. AND HE CAN GET
CORRECTION AND ACCELERATION
WHATEVER THIS TEAM NEEDS. USING
BROADBAND HAPPENING THAT
CHILDREN CAN PARTICIPATE IN
REAL WORLD RESEARCH STUDIES
BEING. CONDUCTED AT
UNIVERSITIES BECAUSE THEY CAN
PUT IN THEIR DATA ONLINE AND
THAT CAN BECOME PART OF THE
RESEARCH STUDY IT'S
EMBARRASSING THAT THE HOME OF
SILICON VALLEY CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT HAVE BROADBAND FOR EVERY
CHILD IN THE STATE AND FOR
EVERY FAMILY IN THE STATE. I
URGE YOU. TO PLEASE DON'T ASK.
ME SURE IT'S TO DO SOMETHING
THAT THEY DO. WITHOUT THE-
YOU'LL TO PASS TO BE US THE-
NOW I URGE YOU TO DO I OR THE
COR TO OF DISPEL. THANK YOU
NETKO WILL MOVE ON TO- RAMOS
WHO'S HERE IN PERSON IN THE-
AUDIENCE. HIS START HERE. WE
REYES. AND HERE- ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON AT ALSO SEE ALSO CTIA
AND OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS TO STRONGLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION NEEDED TO
ACCELERATE THE WIDESPREAD
DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE G. IN
CALIFORNIA. SENATOR WE'VE
APPLIED SENATOR DODD FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS BILL SENATE
ARE LAID OUT WHAT THE BILL DOES
I THINK VERY CLEARLY LET ME
TAKE A MOMENT TO EXPLAIN WHAT
IT DOES NOT DO- SO-FIRST OFF
THIS DOES NOT IMPACT LOCAL
CONTROL. OVER THE SIDING
REPLACEMENT OR STATICS OF SMALL
WIRELESS FACILITIES PLACEMENTS.
THE I AGREE THAT THOSE ISSUES
SHOULD BE HANDLED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ALL THIS DECISION DOES
IS. IMPLEMENTED AND PROVIDE A
REMEDY AND PROCESS FOR THE FCC
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DECISION- THE
BILL ALSO HAS A GRANDFATHERING
CLAUSE THAT PRESERVES EXISTING
AGREEMENTS SO THE WAY I EXPLAIN
IT IS. NEW POLLS NEW RATE ALL
POLLS HOLD RATE IT'S PRETTY
IT'S THAT SIMPLE IT ALSO
PRESERVES THE OF THE ABILITY OF
THE CARRIERS TO WORK WITH
INDIVIDUAL CITIES ON
PARTNERSHIPS ARE FORWARD
LOOKING AGREEMENT. DEFINED A
WIN WIN OPPORTUNITIES AS THE
INDUSTRY AND I'M PROUD TO SAY
VERIZON IS DONE WITH SEVERAL
CALIFORNIA CITIES- AND FINALLY-
THE BILL PRESERVES THIS TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DOLLARS
THANK YOU- SAFE HARBOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH- THE SAFE HARBOR
RATE THAT THE FCC HAS IN CASE
THE CITY. DOES NOT HAVE- THE
DESIRE TO DO THEIR OWN COST ID
THEY CAN USE THE SAME FCC SAFE
HARBOR RATE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF THE CHAIR AND
SENATOR WOULD ALLOW. WOULD
WOULD LIKE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE INTO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND WE
HAVE TWO SPEAKERS THREE OH TWO
THREE THREE EIGHT YOU'LL BE
GIVEN TWO MINUTES APIECE MARC
GRAHAM FROM KEEP CELL OF THE
TENNIS AWAY FROM ELK GROVE
HOMES- WHO'S HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE WITH US. A PAUL
MCGAVIN FROM WHERE CALIFORNIA
THAN FRANK ERA SAVE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA WILL BE ON THE PHONE SO
WE WILL START WITH MR GRAMM
PLEASE. GIVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN MOST
DISTINGUISHED HONORABLE MEMBERS
MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF OF KEEP
CELL ANTENNAS AWAY. PLEASE ASK
ME QUESTIONS AFTER MY
PRESENTATION. WHAT MR REYES
MENTIONED THE PRESERVING
EXISTING AGREEMENTS AND
PRESERVING A STATIC REGULATIONS
IS NOT IN THIS BILL BUT IT MUST
BE PUT INTO THIS BILL AND YOU
SHOULD DO THAT TODAY THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT. BUT IT NEEDS TO BE
WRITTEN IN SB FIVE FIVE SIX IS
SIMPLY BAD POLICY OVER POWERED
CELL ANTENNAS CONSTRUCTED TEN
TO FIFTY FEET AWAY FROM ALREADY
SERVE HOMES WILL NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE DISTANCE
LEARNING TELEHEALTH FOR CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. THE PEOPLE
IN UNDERSERVED LOWER INCOME
AREAS CANNOT AFFORD THE MUCH
TOO HIGH PRICES FOR BROADBAND
WHAT IS NEEDED IS JUST AND
REASONABLE PRICING FROM TITLE
TO REGULATED WIRED INTERNET
FROM STATE PUBLIC UTILITIES.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT LAST
APRIL FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ANNENBERG
SCHOOL FOR COMMUNICATION THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IT'S A PRICE
ISSUE. THERE'S NOTHING SB FIVE
FIVE SIX THAT ADDRESSES AND
USER AFFORDABILITY OR REQUIRES
JUST AND REASONABLE PRICING.
THE BILL IS ALSO VAGUE ON
CERTAIN AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
SECTION FIVE NINE EIGHT ONE A
SAYS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR
LOCAL PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITY SHALL NOT ON REASONABLY.
DENY THE LEASING OR LICENSING
OF ITS STREETLIGHT POLE TO
TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLL FOR SELLING
TEMAS WHAT DOES THAT MEAN. IS
IT REASONABLE FOR A CITY TO
DENY ACCESS CITING FEDERAL LAW
AND FEDERAL AND STATE APPELLATE
COURT OPINIONS. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT RULING T. MOBILE THE SAN
FRANCISCO SAID THE CITY HAS THE
POWER TO SET AESTHETIC
REGULATIONS. TO PRESERVE THE
QUIET ENJOYMENT OF THE STREETS
AND OTHER LOCAL VALUES IS THAT
REASONABLE YES. AS RECENTLY
CONFIRMED BY THE U. S. COURT OF
APPEALS FOR THE NINTH CIRCUIT
UNDER FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION REGULATIONS CITIES
RETAIN LOCAL AUTHORITY TO
IMPOSE REASONABLE A FEW.
SECONDS ON TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS FACILITIES THIRTY
PORTLAND VERSUS UNITED STATES.
CANNOT CITY SITE VAST AND DENY
ACCESS. SELLING KIND OF ONE OF
HOMES ARE NEVER THE LEAST
INTRUSIVE MEANS TO PROVIDE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES. A
VAGUE AND UNCERTAIN LAW USUALLY
WORKS AGAINST THE CITY THE
COUNTY AND THE PEOPLE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR GRAMM URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON SB FIVE FIVE SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
ANNOUNCED MISTER MCGAVIN. AND
MR GALVIN WELCOME. WELL YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AUDIBLE CHAIRED
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'M PAUL THE
GAVEL FROM WIRE CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF NEARLY
FOUR MILLION ELECTROMAGNETIC
SENSE OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
SCRAMBLING TO FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE AND WORK. THAT ARE NOT
THOROUGHLY POLLUTED WITH
EXCESSIVE ELECTROMAGNETIC POWER
THROUGH THE AIR PLEASE ASK ME
QUESTIONS LATER. THIS IS
GETTING HARDER AND HARDER TO DO
IS WE'RE CONTINUING BEING
TORTURED AND FORCED TO MOVE DUE
TO EXCESSIVE POWER THROUGH THE
AIR BY BIG WIRELESS. COMPANIES
WHO ARE BAMBOOZLING YOU INTO
ACCEPTING WIRELESS BROADBAND AS
A SOLUTION TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE THEY HAVE NO PREEMPTION
FOR WIRELESS BROADBAND ONLY FOR
WIRELESS TELECOMMUNICATION
SERVICE. PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT
NEWS FLASH WIRELESS WELL DO IT
THESE BILLS ARE WORSE INDUSTRY
TRIP OF THE PLAY FOR TWO
DECADES WRAP THEIR BUSINESS
GOALS AROUND A CURRENT MEAN.
AND POINT YOU TO OF COURSE
WIRELESS AS THE SOLUTION I'M
HERE TO POINT YOU TO THE
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE WHICH IS
ALREADY BEEN ENTERED INTO THE
PUBLIC RECORD. IN THE BILLS
FOR. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AB
FIVE FIVE SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AB 239-520-0017 SB SIX
FOUR NINE ONCE AGAIN. IN THE
BILLS FOR THE TRIPLE THREAT SIX
SEVEN EIGHT THREE CALIFORNIA
FOR STRUCTURE BILLS THAT MISSED
THE MARK BY DESTROYING LOCAL
CONTROL OVER BOTH FIBER OPTIC
INSTALLATIONS AND WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT WOULD BE
SB FIVE FIVE SIXTY FIVE THREE
SEVEN AND AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT.
THE BEST TELECOM ANALYSIS IN
THE COUNTRIES IN YOUR RECORD
APRIL FOURTEEN IN MAY TEN
LETTERS FROM ATTORNEY HARRY
LEHMANN. JUNE FIRST AND JUNE
EIGHTH LETTER FROM ATTORNEY
GERRY WOMEN. VOLUMES OF DATA
FOR PRESCRIPTION FOR THE
REGULATORS TO DC CIRCUIT COURT
RULING IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY GIVES YOU THE SOLUTION
TO THE DIGITAL BY. SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS THERE WERE
MISAPPROPRIATED FROM CALIFORNIA
TO BUILD THE FOUR G. NETWORK
GOAL BACK AND GET IT. IT WILL
SOLVE THE DIGITAL VIED WITH THE
PUBLIC UTILITY THAT WAY YOU
COULD JUST EVERY EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER MCGAVIN THOUGHT NOW
WOULD BE FRANK ERA SAY I
BELIEVE HE'S. ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE. THE
FOR NO. LOOKING FOR FRANK FRANK
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU
OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER MEMBERS
UP. I AM FRANK OBSTINATE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
ABOUT. ON BEHALF OF THE MORE
THAN SIXTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
BECAUSE THE IDEA TO BY THE
POLLS SB FIVE BY SIX. THIS BILL
WOULD REPORTER PUBLIC SAFETY BY
CREATING SHORT PROVIDING
DEADLINES CANADA GIVEAWAY TO
PRIVATE INDUSTRY ON THE BACKS
OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES. ALL WHILE
DOING NOTHING TO HOLD INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTABLE SB FIVE BY SIX
COULD TAKE OVERLY STRICT
TIMELINES AND LIMIT THE ABILITY
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO COLLECT
THREE. THIS IS A SWEET HEART
GIVEAWAY TO THE INDUSTRY AND
FAVORED THE INDUSTRY'S BOTTOM
LINE OVERTAKE PEOPLE WORKERS
AND THE PUBLIC THE FULL REVIEW
OF PERMIT APPLICATIONS. THE W.
I HAVE STUDIED THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROCESS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AND IT'S FOUND THAT
TO REVIEW IT'S CRUCIAL FOR
STATES ARE ALREADY WAS CRUCIAL
FOR SAFETY. UNFORTUNATELY SB
FIVE FIVE SIX MAKES PERMITTING
PROCESS WORSE FOR WORKERS AND
THE PUBLIC THANK PUBLIC SHORTEN
TIMEFRAMES WOULD TIE THE HANDS
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DURING THE
REVIEW. LOCAL MEMORY KEY TO
HELP TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
INFLATION THE CONDUCTOR
BASICALLY BY PROPERLY TRAINED
WORKERS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT SUBCONTRACTORS DON'T
ENDANGER THE PUBLIC OR OTHER
WORKERS. ON THE RIGHT AWAY
BIGELOW CONTRIBUTED REPORT
PUBLISHED IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR
BY THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS OFFICERS AND
ADVISORS THE BIG HELP ALONG
WITH THE PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH UNFAIR APPLICATION
TIMELINE COULD RESTRICTIVE
TREATS. LIKE THE ONE PROPOSED
BY SB FIVE BY SIX FOR EXAMPLE
THE REPORT PARK THAT FOUR OUT
OF FIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENT SURVEY
REPORT THAT PROVIDERS REGULARLY
PROVIDE INPUT COMPLETE
APPLICATIONS. NOTHING IN THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THE FAILURE OF
APPLICANTS TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW WORK TO STRENGTHEN THE
PENALTIES THAT WILL NOT BY.
REPORT ALSO DETAILS OVER 50% OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RESPONDED TO
REPORTS THAT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
DOLLARS CAUSED DAMAGE TO PUBLIC
PROPERTY AND OR FAILED TO
PROPERLY STORE PUBLIC PROPERTY.
OFTEN IN THE SITUATION ITS
LOCAL TAXPAYERS HAVE TO PICK UP
THE TAB NOTHING ELECTRIFIED BY
TICKS REQUIRED TO PROPERLY
TRAINED WORK FORCE TO CONDUCT
THE INSTALLATION. OF THE REPORT
YOU AS A RESULT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PUBLIC SAFETY
PROBLEMS LIKE THE UNLIKELY.
CONTRACTOR IN SEPARATE THANK
YOU. THE BILL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TEST I KNOW FIVE SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE CENTER DOG
WOULD YOU MY JUST A- GETTING
ESTABLISH YOUR QUORUM PLEASE
MA'AM THAT'S- WE ARE. HERE AT
PRESS LACK. LACKEY PRESENT
BLOOM. WILL PRESENT BURGER.
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER PRESENT
VOEPEL RIGHT HOTEL PRESS WE
HAVE A COOL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS STEMS A QUORUM WILL MOVE
ON WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO- WITNESS.
ON THE PHONE LINE WE ARE FIRST
GOING TO TAKE THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL JUST
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION
OF THE BILL ONLY OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN THE LINE TO
THOSE THAT WERE. PART OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN
RIGHT THANK YOU APPROACH ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIND THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PROPERTY RIGHT
OR AT YES I MARTIN BURN BOMB
PRIVATE CITIZENS AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. WE ARE NOW TAKING THOSE
BUYING GUIDE THANK YOU. BY
NINETY FOUR HAD. IS THIS
REGARDING IT SB NINE NO IT'S
NOT THIS IS NOT THIS IS- SB
FIVE FIVE SIX WE ARE TAKING
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL JUST NAME. OUR ORGANIZED
IN YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT HERE. IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR CELL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO POINT
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ROXANNE GOULD
REPRESENTING THE WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN
ARE WILL COME OUT AND
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FIND FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVEN THE
ACT BOWLING I'M AN ENGINEER AND
A MEMBER OF THE C. W. A. UNION
ON THIS ISSUE I'M SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF AND I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY SIX
PLANES CRASHED. ONE ONE EIGHT
SIX- MY NAME IS LESLIE SIMON
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. I'LL
JUST REMIND THOSE THAT ARE GOOD
BY GETTING ON THE LNE WE WERE
LOOKING FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
FOR SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK
YOU. YOU'RE RIGHT ONE NINETY
TWO PLEASE FOR AT. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
KAREN PROGRAM. I'M WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR RESPONSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU A LOT OF ENTRIES FOR
AT THE. MY NAME IS SAM HAN.
THERE ARE V. AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
SO ONCE AGAIN LET ME REMIND
EVERYONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO CALL
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. JUST
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY THANK YOU. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU WISH TO TAKE
YOURSELF OUT OF Q. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS
NEED SOME LOVE ON BEHALF OF
CROWN CASTLE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CTIA THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WON THIRTY NINE SEATS FOR AT.
HI THIS IS RYAN LANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE FORTY SEVENTIES GORE HAD.
NINE ONE FOUR SEVEN. TRYING TO
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. THIRTY TWO. RIGHT
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT BOOKBINDER CITY CAMPBELL
DISTRICT TWENTY EIGHT CALLING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK CHIU FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SUSAN PETERSON
WEBER WITH T. MOBILE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. RIGHT ONE
TWENTY NINETY FOUR HAD. ONE ONE
TWO NINE. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WILL NOW MOVE INTO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND LET ME REMIND
EVERYONE AGAIN THIS IS
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. A
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. EMAIL TO
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE ZERO AGAIN. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIFTY
LINES IN Q. I'M GOING TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILL BE
ASKED TO LEAVE THE SHOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
OPPOSITION ALSO TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND OPPOSITION OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TWO
OR THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY
SHOULD THERE ARE ONLY THREE. I
TERMINATE ME YES QUALITY. WE I
THOUGHT YOU DON'T ON BEHALF OF
THANK YOU THANK YOU DON'T COME
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON
SEVENTY EIGHT SEATS FOR ADDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS
ERIC O'DONNELL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH MISSION VIEJO DEL MAR
BREA CHINO HILLS AND PLACENTIA
OWN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY SEVENTY
NINE THREE FOUR HAD. MY NAME IS
MADE LANGSTAFF AND I OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN YEAH. THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS CONSTANCE ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF WIRED- WIRELESS
RADIATION EDUCATION OF FANS- I
STRONGLY OPPOSE FIVE FIVE SIX
I'M A RESIDENT CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND ONE OF THE FOUR.
THANK YOU RUN ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CATHERINE DOT
EVER REGISTERED NURSE
REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE OF
NURSES FOR A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE A STRONG
OPPOSE HONESTY FIVE FIVE SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AYE CHIU FORTY PLEASE GO ASK.
THIS IS GREAT LOWER BIRTH I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO. FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWO ZERO EIGHT. HELLO HELLO.
HI MY NAME IS GENTLE TENDER
COMING OUT OF MANCHESTER CITY
HAS TO COUNTY HIGH STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WON EIGHTY SIX PLEASE CALL AT.
LESLIE'S I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GRAD. HI
THIS WAY- CABRAL'S W. A LOCAL
NINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RANCHO THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
SYDNEY **** AND I REPRESENT TWO
HUNDRED ACTIVISTS WITH SAFE
TEXAS SANTA ROSA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M CHIU FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS PATRICK WELCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SURE TO
PLEASE GO ASK. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS REGINA MCKENZIE I'M A
HOMEOWNER AND I OPPOSE THANK
YOU. J. HEARING FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
KELLY MURPHY WITH CW A LOCAL
NINETY FOUR HUNDRED AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FIVE SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARON BYRNE MONDAY EITHER WITH
THE PATIENT STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NINE ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE CALL AT. THE
COLD WATER FLOWS FREE MOUNT
SHASTA STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE CALL ASK. YES MY
NAME'S JOSEPH MARTINEZ WHAT'S
THE W. A LOCAL NINETY FOUR TEN
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I'VE
CLOSED FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIVE SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DAN CONKLIN WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
RESPECTIVELY IN OPPOSITION TO
FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU. BY
NINETY FOUR PLEASE CALL ADDRESS.
HI THIS IS SHAWN DAVIS I'M FROM
PARK MAKES HEIGHTS COMMUNITY
LAND PLANS TO MEET TOM
DEPARTMENT I'M SPEAKING OF
STAKEHOLDER TODAY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE CALL AT.
AND CONTROLLED LONG BEACH I
STRONGLY OPPOSES FOR HELP
CONCERNING FEW. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS JEFF LERNER IN
FAIRFAX AND THE TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M ONE TWENTY
SEVEN THREE FOUR HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SHARING THOSE ALL THAT BUT THE
READY PUBLIC POLICY GROUPS ON
THE OPPOSITE. CORONA CARL AT
THE LAW WHAT'S YOUR CITY AND-
THE AT FIVE I THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M ONE SHIFT
THREE AT. THE CASE REPRESENT
THE E. SAFETYNET STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
MORE. NINETY EIGHT FOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS NINA LATE ON
BEHALF THE CITY OF THOUSAND
OAKS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SERRA HUMBLING I
LIVE IN CALABASAS CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINETY TWO PLEASE FOR AT.
IN THIS IS CHRIS BEAUCHAMP WITH
PWA LOCAL NINETY FIVE ELEVEN
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY YEAH MY
NAME IS AJ- HARNAM WITH- CW A
LOCAL NINETY FIVE OH FIVE AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THANK
YOU SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND YOUR MIND SIXTY
PLEASE GLAD. YEAH JOHNSON W.
EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY ONE SPACECRAFT. SCOTT
TURNER COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMERI CALL
CAN CANCER SOCIETY SILICON
VALLEY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHECK GROCERY
REVIEWER LOCAL NINETY FOUR
TWELVE HILL CALIFORNIA POST
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M ONE OF
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. STEPHANIE
THOMAS- FROM WIRELESS RADIATION
EDUCATION DISTANCE FROM
BERKELEY STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AT. DURING A
WHAT'S IN WITH THE WA LOCAL
NINETY FOUR HUNDRED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. YOU'RE RIGHT TO
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR AT. ZACH
OUCH PRESIDENCY WA LOCAL NINETY
FOUR AWAY AND WE OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I NINETY THREE
PLEASE KALRA. HI WELL BEFORE I
TELL YOU- I MUST TELL YOU THAT
I WAS NOT NEVER GIVEN A NUMBER
UNTIL JUST NOW WHEN I SAID IS
THAT ME ABOUT TWENTY TIMES IN A
DAY SOMEONE CAME ON THE LINE
GAVE ME NO YOU NEED TO KNOW THE
PEOPLE THAT. I DID. IN TERMS
OF. BUYING. SIXTEEN RIGHT SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
HELLO HELLO YES MY YES RIGHT I
AM- A RESIDENT HERE IN PALO UP
MUCH MY NAME IS ELLEN HARDTALK
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
TOM REPORTER FROM STATE TECH
FROM SANTA ROSA. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT OR NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO ASK. HELLO MY
NAME IS ANDREA B. NAMASTE I
LIVE IN ANGER CALIFORNIA. I'M
ELECTED CONSERVATIVE OPPOSED S.
FIVE SIX S. AMENDED TO PROMOTE
WIRED ACCIDENTALLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DEREN
WESTBROOK. THE W. EIGHT NINE
FOUR TWO THREE OPPOSED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RANGE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAUL YODER ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN OPPOSITION
AND ALSO THE COUNTY OF SOLANO
STILL HAS. CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE CALL AT. MONICA ALVIN I
AM A HOMEOWNER AND A RESIDENT
AND MARIN COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JANET BUILT ON THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FIVE BY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I WON EIGHTY STRIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAROL
PLEASE STAND UP I LIVE IN
PACIFIC GROVE AND I AM
ASSOCIATE AND TONI COUPLE BUT
EMS SERVICES I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND I HAVE A FRIEND
WHO'S SITTING ON A SEPARATE
LINE WITH. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO OUT AND.
MY NAME'S LAVON MILLER. LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA AND I. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FIFTEEN PLEASE
GLAD. JENNIFER LAPORTE JR WITH
KNOWLEDGE YOU FOR SANTA ROSA
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS DISASTROUS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE FIFTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO FORTY FIVE TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I YES I AM MY NAME IS
HANNAH YOU KNOW I'M NOT AN
ENGINEER FROM GARDEN GROVE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
ONE FIVE. THANK YOU. FOR FIVE
FIVE SIX. PLEASE FOR HAD. WHAT
LINE BY NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS KAREN BURNS IN PALM
SPRINGS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
S. B. FIVE FIVE SIX. IF YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL ASK ANY COKE FROM
LONG BEACH STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS LAUREN DREAMER FROM
SAUSALITO CALIFORNIA I'M
REPRESENTING MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB FIVE SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RUN ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TERRA
AM AT ALL I'M A TEACHER AND SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
GOING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
TO THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
HELP WITH THE CITIES OF
STOCKTON AND GLENDALE AND THE
TOWN OF TRUCKEE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RANGERS SIXTY NINE THREE
FOUR HAD. MY NAME IS THERE WAS
A PARTY FROM THE CITY OF LAKE
ELSINORE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY ON IT HE FIVE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE HUNDRED
SEATS FOR ADDED. THAT WE BURKE
WITHIN THEIR FOR PET
REPRESENTING OUR AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
ALL FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SORENSON WITH
COMMUNICATIONWORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN VERY
STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
FIVE SPECS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAMIE TUCKER
ON BEHALF OF THAT BUDGET
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND WE STRONGLY BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RANGERS SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
STEVIE SORKIN AND CALLING ON
BEHALF OF WIRELESS RADIATION
EDUCATION AND DEFENSE AND WE
HAVE MEMBERS IN DIFFERENT
CITIES AND TOWNS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ALL AGREED NO ON FIVE
FIVE SIX WE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CARL. MY NAME IS CARLTON
CAPELIN I'M A TEACHER. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU OPERATOR WE WILL
TAKE THREE MORE FROM PEOPLE OF
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU BRING
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THE WRONG OF. WELCOME WITH MANY
KIDS ORGANISM AMERICA IT TOOK
NINE AND I SENT. UP AND SIT IN
OUR- THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE FORTY THREE FOUR AT. TWO
ONE FOUR ZERO. RIGHT TO NINETY
THREE SCORE AT. MY NAME'S YOU
DIDN'T INTERCONNECTED LIVE IN
CALABASAS CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. TWO NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES AND WCWA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE FIVE SB
FIVE BUT THANK YOU AN OPERATOR
THANK YOU FOR- GETTING THOSE
PHONE CALLS THROUGH FOR US AS
WE STATED EARLIER WE WERE ONLY
TAKING FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
SUPPORT FOR AND OPPOSITION THIS
AFTERNOON. HOWEVER IF YOU ARE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY WITHIN THAT FIFTEEN
MINUTE PERIOD PLEASE SUBMIT
WRITTEN TO THIS TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE DURING THAT
TIME- WILL OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY SHARON THANK
YOU SENATOR- DOT FROM BRINGING
THIS- VERY ISSUE AS FAR AS-
BRIDGING THE- DIVIDE BROADBAND
DIVIDE AND INTERNET TO OUR
AREAS. YOU HEARD UP SEVERAL
SPEAKERS TOP AND- IN
PARTICULARLY A CITY OF MY
DISTRICT RANCHO CUCAMONGA HAS
RAISED CONCERNS OVER LOCAL
CONTROL. I JUST WANTED TO- SEE
IF YOU COULD ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON THAT AND IF THERE
IS CONTINUING ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS-
TO TRY TO ADDRESS AND CONTACT
COME TO SOME. MEETING OF THE
MINDS ON THOSE ISSUES YES THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PER SHEET
THAT THAT THE QUESTION WE'VE
BEEN WORKING- FOR A LONG TIME
ON ON THIS BILL. I FRANKLY IN
MY DISTRICT I HAD TWENTY OUT OF
TWENTY TWO CITIES WRITING IN
LETTERS TO THE SENATE OPPOSING
THIS BILL. AND NONE OF WHICH
HAVE WRITTEN A LETTER NOW FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN I'M NOT
SURE- THAT ALL THE DIFFERENT
CITIES. HAVE YOU KNOW. EITHER
READ OR UNDERSTOOD THE
AMENDMENTS THAT FRANKLY THIS
BILL NOW- COMPARED TO PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF SOMETHING- THAT
WAS TRIED UP LIKE THREE OR FOUR
YEARS AGO- GIVES WAY MORE-
DISCRETION TO- YOU KNOW TO THE
CITIES. WE CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
THAT'S BEEN MY POINT OF CONTACT
I'VE GOT A GREAT RELATIONSHIP-
WITH- AND I MEET WITH THEM-
YEAH. WHAT WHAT WHAT WHATEVER
THEY WANTED TO DISCUSS IT MOST
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES RECENTLY IS ABOUT
EQUITY. AND WE THINK THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT THERE
RIGHT IN THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHEN WE TALK TO THEM
THEIR MAJOR CONCERN AT THE TIME
IT MAY NOT BE IT MAY BE
DIFFERENT TODAY. I HEARD THEM
ON THE PHONE WITH EQUITY AND-
WE BELIEVE THAT WILL HAVE A
REALLY IMPRESSIVE- A MEMBER TO
THE NEXT GUY COMMITTEE HEARING
IS THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH SO
I. AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THAT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- ENOUGH FOR THE CITY'S
BEING ALL TO CAN TO DIE. WELL
I'M WITH CITY IS WELL AS THERE
PRODUCTS CONCERNS ALSO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AS IT MOVES CLOSER
TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- WITH YOUR
PERMISSION. COULD WE HAVE ONE
OF THE TECHIES COME UP. RISE IN
PERSON- PLEASE SIR MR RAYOS
WHICH LIKE HIM TO COME UP THERE
YES. RIGHT CALIFORNIA. YEAH YOU
GOTTA MYSTERIES MAY IT PLEASE
THE CHAIR YES OKAY YES HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I HAVE A
MILITARY ELECTRONICS BACKGROUND
IN FACT I WAS A RETIREMENT SO
THESE QUESTIONS WILL BE IN THE
WEEDS A LITTLE BIT BUT FIRST A
PARTICULAR REASON. FIVE GMI AND
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING
I'M ABOUT TO SAY JUMP RIGHT IN
OKAY YES I MAKE SURE I HAVE MY
HEAD WRAPPED AROUND THIS BILL
BECAUSE I'D LIKE THE BILL IT'S
A GOOD ONE THANK YOU SIR AND
THE REASON IT'S A GOOD ONE IS.
FIVE G. IS DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGY
FROM OTHER CELLULAR PLANS FIVE
G. IS A TECHNOLOGICAL
BREAKTHROUGH THIS IS A GREAT
LEAP FORWARD I CAN'T WAIT TO
SEE SIX GB. THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND IT IT MEETS THE SAME
SAFETY STANDARDS IS EQUIPMENT
USED IN CURRENT NETWORKS
CORRECT YES SIR. ROGER THAT.
AND THIS IS A UNIQUE SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT'S MADE UP OF
HUNDREDS OF VERY SMALL ANTENNA
THEY'RE IN A REYES TO MAXIMIZE
SIGNALS AND THAT RESULTS IN
VERY LOW RADIO WAVE EXPOSURE
CALL BEING FOR ME IS THAT
CORRECT. YES SIR. GOOD EXPOSURE
LEVELS WOULD BE BELOW
INTERNATIONAL SAFETY LIMITS
WHICH IS TWENTY FOUR POINT TWO
FIVE GIGAHERTZ. AND ABOVE. IT
THE WAY I UNDERSTAND THE
INTERNATIONAL SAFETY LIMITS IS
THERE. THERE MOST STRINGENT IS
IN THE EUROPEAN UNION SO WE'RE
BELOW THE EUROPEAN UNION THE
WAY I UNDERSTAND IT FOR SAFETY
IS THAT CORRECT WHAT I WOULD
SAY THAT THAT THAT THE BILL
CONFORMS TO THE FCC SAFETY
STANDARDS WHICH ARE VERY STRICT
YES ALL RIGHT ALSO FROM MY
RESEARCH FIVE G. CANNOT
PENETRATE WALLS MOST FIVE G.
NOT ALL WANNA MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR. COULD NOT PENETRATE
GLASS SO CELLULAR FIVE G. IS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT FROM WIFI
WIFI GOES THROUGH WALLS AND GO
THROUGH YOUR WHOLE HOUSE AND
PEOPLE WILL. SIT ON OUR
COMPUTERS WITH A WIFI RIGHT
NEXT TO NOT EVEN THINKING TWICE
ABOUT RF ENERGY. SO I FIND IT
KIND OF IRONIC. SO MADAM CHAIR
I SEEM TO BE ON THE RIGHT TRACK
HERE AS FAR AS THE
TECHNICALITIES SO I'M GOOD OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL DOES
ANYONE ELSE YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BORA HORMONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION- I THINK
FIVE G. IS GOING TO ABSOLUTELY
TRANSFORM HOW WE CONNECT WITH
EACH OTHER AND WE CAN'T EVEN
IMAGINE. THE WORLD AS IT'S
GOING TO BE IN TERMS OF
CONNECTIVITY I DON'T THINK IF
YOU WOULD HAVE ASKED US ALL TEN
YEARS AGO MOVIES SITTING HERE
WITH SMARTPHONES AND ALL THE
STUFF. YOU KNOW OR MAYBE TEN
YEARS AGO FOR TWENTY YEARS AGO
WHO WAS SITTING HERE WITH MY
PHONE I DON'T THINK WE WOULD
HAVE KNOWN THAT SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO DO THAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ALL MY CITIES OPPOSE
YOUR BILL. AND YOU SAID YOU
WERE ALREADY WORKING WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND MY
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THEIR
OPPOSITION HAS TO DO WITH
ACTUALLY THE DETAIL OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. CURRENT
FEDERAL LAW AND WHAT YOUR BILL
IS PROPOSING WHICH IS UNDER
CURRENT FEDERAL LAW CITIES
DON'T HAVE TO PROPOSE A REMEDY
IN YOUR BILL. REQUIRES THEM TO
PROPOSE A REMEDY IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT SO I
HOPE WE CONTINUE TO DO IT YES
SIR YOU'RE RIGHT I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I'M TELLING. I. SPENT
A LOT. WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS A LOT OF TRYING
TO OUT THE EXACT OPPOSITION A
HE SO I. IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE
AFFORD BECAUSE I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF SEEING THIS AND
COMMUNICATION COMMAND AND ON
THE FLOOR AGAIN- TO WORK OUT.
WHAT HAPPENS OF THE CITY
DETERMINES THAT THERE'S NO
REMEDY. AND TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
IS THE APPROPRIATE TIME LINE
ESPECIALLY FOR VERY SMALL
CITIES. TO BE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH THAT REMEDY VERY SMALL
CITIES I DON'T HAVE VERY SMALL
CITIES MUCH MORE CITIES SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND. THEY PROBABLY
HAVE STUFF TO DO IN THE TIME
FRAME IS BEING PROPOSED. I
THINK SOME OF THE SMALLER
CITIES WON'T. SO IF YOU COULD
THINK ABOUT THAT. AND THE THIRD
THING I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. IS I
THINK AS THIS TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES. IT IS VERY POSSIBLE
THAT FEDERAL GUIDELINES CAN
CHANGE. SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOUR BILL SAYS ABOUT BECAUSE
YOUR BILL IS BASICALLY SAYING.
WE'RE GONNA DEFINE WHAT THE
FEDERAL LAW MEANS FOR
CALIFORNIA CORRECT. CORRECT SO
AS THAT FEDERAL LAW CHANGES WE
DON'T TO BE STUCK WITH A LAW.
THAT DOES NOT REFLECT OVER
CONSTANTLY COMING BACK HERE TO
RE EVALUATE WHAT IT IS. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE THOUGHTS
ON IF FEDERAL LAW WERE TO
CHANGE. AND FIVE MONTHS SIX
MONTHS. WHAT WOULD THE IMPACT
BE IN CALIFORNIA AND HOW WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE AND THAT IN YOUR
BILL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME
UNFORTUNATELY- IF WE PUT
SOMETHING IN STATUTE THAT
ROLLED OVER EVERY FEDERAL-
CHANGE THE CAME UP A BOARD-
WITH IT IN IN FACT. THAT WOULD
TAKE AWAY- DECISION MAKING- YOU
KNOW FROM THIS BODY IN TERMS OF
IF THAT'S WHAT THEY WANTED
GOING FORWARD SO. ESSENTIALLY
IF THERE WAS A BIG CHANGE IN
FEDERAL LAW THAT REALLY-
INTERFERED- WITH WITH THE STATE
LAW THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO- OPINED
ON IT WOULD GO THROUGH A
DIFFERENT- BILL BUT IT. MISTER
REYES HAS ANOTHER COMMENT ON
THAT WHICH IS YES YES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT SENATOR DODD
IS RIGHT IN FACT I THINK THE
INDUSTRY WOULD LIKE. TO SEE. IT
BECAUSE IS THIS WITH FEDERAL
LAW OVER TIME BUT- WITH RISK.
ALLEGE COUNTS IS PUSH BACK
EIGHT THAT AS A SEAT OF SAAB.
FROM THE STATE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. OKAY AND THEN MY
LAST COLUMN IT WILL BE ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE I DID SERVE ON THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES- HOUSING
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- SUBCOMMITTEE.
WHILE THE PREVIOUS BILL WAS
GOING TO THE LEGISLATURE SO I
REMEMBER ALL THOSE LOVELY
CONVERSATIONS. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I SAID THEN THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER YOU BECAUSE I
WILL GET TO SEE THIS AGAIN
AGAIN. I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST TRADE US WE NEED TO
MAKE. IS IF WE'RE GOING TO ASK
CITIES TO TAKE THE EXTRA STEP.
AND PROVIDE A REMEDY. THEN
THERE SHOULD BE A PUBLIC
BENEFIT. THERE SHOULD BE YOU
KNOW WHY. YOU KNOW FIVE G. AT
LIBRARIES AT SCHOOL SITES
PARKS. PLACES WHERE PEOPLE WHO
EVEN IF THE WHAT FIVE G.
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. BECAUSE MAYBE IT'S
NOT PROFITABLE FOR THAT
DISTRIBUTION. THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING IN THOSE PUBLIC
SPACES BECAUSE WE ARE PROVIDING
A PUBLIC BENEFIT. I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A PUBLIC BENEFIT
BACKSIDE LIKE TO OFFER THAT
WITH YOU. I WILL SUPPORT THIS
TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THESE AMENDMENTS AND HEARING
HOW YOUR CONVERSATIONS. WITH
THE LEAGUES ARE GOING AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY LOCAL
CITIES. TO GET US TO A PLACE BY
THE TIME IT GETS TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE- THAT THERE'S MORE
AGREEMENT THERE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE- SO
MANY MEMBERS MANY SAYING NONE-
YOU KNOW TEN EMOTION. SO SECOND.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION FOR-
SOMEONE VOEPEL AFFECT BIASA
REMEMBER- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. RIGHT YOU KNOW-
CENTER DODD I APPRECIATE THE
WORK ON THIS BILL AND WE ALL
KNOW THE PASSIONATE COMMITMENT
TO EXPAND BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN OUR STATE
WE ALONG WITH MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE WORKING ON
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THIS PUZZLE
THAT WE HOPE TO CREATE A
COMPLETE PICTURE. WHEN WE'RE
DONE. ONE WITHOUT ANY HOLES OR
BLANK SPACE. WELL WE SHARE THE
SCHOOL I ALSO SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS A CALL TO DISCUSS
TODAY. RIGHT NOW FROM OUR
DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU AGREE THAT
WE NEED TO FIND REAL SOLUTIONS
TO THE PERSISTENT PROBLEMS OF
ACCESS. ADOPTION AFFORDABILITY.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY WITH YOUR COMMITMENT THAT
YOU WILL BE ADOPTING LANGUAGE
TO ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
BEFORE THE BILL REACHES THE
FLOOR. I'D APPRECIATE YOU
SHOWING THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE
WHEN THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS SOON AS YOU CAN-
WITH THAT- I APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR WORK YOU KNOW THIS IS A
PASSION TO ME. BUT THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO COMMUNICATIONS
A CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-
HI. AGUIAR-CURRY ALRIGHT LACKEY.
LACKEY I BLOOM. WILL NOT
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I ROBLES WELL
AS I LOSE HI THREE OF US I ROB.
ROBERT RIVAS I WILL HI L. R.
SEVEN- BILLS HAS OF EVERYBODY
SEVEN ZERO OKAY SEVEN BILL OUT
LOOKS LIKE A THEY YOU VERY MUCH
FIRST- NEXT WEEK MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO. S. B. TH SO
EIGHT. SENATOR GONZALEZ WELCOME.
NICE TO SEE YOU TO AND START
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND BEFORE I BEGIN
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGES FOUR AND
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS THAT
CLARIFY THE FEE AMOUNT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CAN CHARGE YOU FIBER
INSTALLER FOR A PERMIT TO MICRO
TRENCH AND REMOVE REDUNDANT
LANGUAGE- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO RESS
TO PRESENT SB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
IS A KEY COMPONENT TO CLOSING
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND I'VE HAD
THE PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU
ON MANY BROADBAND POLICIES AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT THIS IS
ANOTHER PIECE THIS WILL HELP
PROMOTE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY REQUIRING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ALLOW FIBER
CABLES TO BE INSTALLED USING
COST EFFECTIVE TECHNIQUES
INCLUDING OPEN TRENCHING BORING
OR MICRO TRENCHING. THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A BEST PRACTICES
STANDARD FOR MICRO CHANGING IN
RELATION TO DEPLOYING BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE CURRENTLY EVERY
JURISDICTION IS DOING SOMETHING
A BIT DIFFERENT AND WE NEED TO
STANDARDIZE THAT STANDARDIZES
SO WE CAN ENSURE THAT BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT IS FAST RELIABLE AND
LESS INVASIVE. IT'LL ADDRESS
THE LACK OF CONTINUITY BY
CREATING A STATEWIDE STANDARD
FOR MICRO TRENCHING AS A
DEPLOYMENT OPTION FOR
BROADBAND. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE DENNIS
WISER DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS WITH CROWN CASTLE. AS
WELL AS ERIKA HOFFMANN
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MCH OPERATOR WE'RE
LOOKING FOR DAN SCHWEITZER FROM
CROWN CASTLE FOR ERICA HOFFMAN
AND WE'RE- TALKINGFROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION BOTH ON THE PHONE.
BOTH THEIR OPENERS. HI CHAIR
NUMBER USUALLY MAKES ALL OF ON
BEHALF OF DAN SCHNEIDER I'D
REPRESENT CROWN CASTLE HE
ACTUALLY JUST GOT PULLED INTO A
MEETING TRYING TO DO A
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT- PROJECT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD
TO SPONSOR SB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW
BROADBAND PROJECTS TO BE BUILT
QUICKER WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
REDUCING CONSTRUCTION IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL ENSURES
THAT THE INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICE
OF MICRO TRENCHING IS ALLOWED
BY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
INSTALL HIGH SPEED INTERNET
FIBER CABLES UNDERGROUND.
MICHAEL CRINGING TECHNOLOGY
CUTS A TWO INCH WIDE AND TWO
FOOT DEEP TRENCH TO LAY THE
FIBER UNDERGROUND. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY BACK FILLING AND
SEALING. THE ENTIRE PROCESS
TAKES HOURS AND CARS CAN DRIVE
ON THE ROAD THE SAME DAY. MICRO
TRENCHING IS TYPICALLY 60%
CHEAPER AND 80% QUICKER THAN
TRADITIONAL OPEN FRENCH STREET
EXCAVATIONS. WHICH CREATE LANE
CLOSURES AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT
NEIGHBORHOODS. THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS BEING USED IN CITIES AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY DEPLOYED IN LOS
ANGELES WERE OVER FORTY MILES
OF FIBER. HAS BEEN INSTALLED IN
RECENT MONTHS- IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE HESITANT TO
UTILIZE THIS NEWER TECHNOLOGY
THAT CITY STAFF FOR USED TO THE
OLDER MORE DESTRUCTIVE METHOD
OF OPEN TRENCHING. MICHAEL
TRENCHING COMPLIES WITH ALL
UTILITY SAFETY RULES AND GOES
FURTHER BY USING GROUND
PENETRATING RADAR PRIOR TO
INSTALLATION. QUICKER
INSTALLATION OF FIBER MEANS
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE
CAN GET CONNECTED TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET AND DAYS INSTEAD OF
MONTHS. THIS WILL COMPLEMENT
THE STATE'S EFFORT TO PROVIDE
MORE FUNDING FOR BROADBAND BY
ENSURING THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
DOLLARS ARE MAXIMISED AND
BENEFIT RESIDENTS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. WE CAN ENSURE
AGUIAR-CURRY AND CENTER
GONZALEZ FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
ADVANCING BROADBAND IN THE
STATE AN ASTRONAUT VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
NOW WILL HAVE ERICA HOFFMAN
PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS ERICA HOFFMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION CFTA IS COMMITTED
TO BROADBAND EXPANSION IN
CALIFORNIA TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE IMPROVE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
AT THE LAST YEAR HAS SHOWN NOW
MORE THAN EVER THE STATE NEEDS
TO DO ALL IT CAN CONNECT OUCH
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR SCHOOLS TO
HIGH SPEED INTERNET WE SUPPORT
IT SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
BECAUSE IN THE SHORT. THAT THE
INDUSTRY PRACTICE OF MICHAEL
TENSION TENSION CAN BE USED TO
QUICKLY INSTALL FIBER. FOR HIGH
SPEED INTERNET PROJECTS THIS
BILL WILL HAVE A MEANINGFUL
IMPACT BY ALLOWING FIBER TO BE
INSTALLED IN HOURS. INSTEAD OF
WEEKS AND EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT
IT WILL BE DISCUSSED BLESSED
DISRUPTIVE WITHIN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND SCHOOLS
RETURN FOR BOTH SUMMER PROGRAMS
AND IN THE FALL. EDUCATION
OPTIONS WILL BE PROVIDED
STUDENTS INCLUDING VIRTUAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. AND MANY
MANY TEACHERS THESE DAYS ARE
ESTABLISHING HOMEWORK BASED
UPON DIGITAL PLATFORMS. THE
BILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AND WITHOUT ACCESS STUDENTS
WILL NOT PROGRESS AND SUCCEED.
SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO HELP
EXPEDITE BROADBAND ACCESSTO
COMMUNITIES IN NEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU ALL HAVE BEEN DOING ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOT DO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE IN THE
IN PERSON HERE. MARK GRAHAM
FROM KIT- KEEP CELL ANTENNAS
AND PALMA GAVIN FROM WHERE
CALIFORNIA IF YOU'D LIKE TO
APPROACH THE- MICROPHONE. THREE
WE'LL GO BACK AND. AND YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES THIS TIME LAST
TIME YOU THREE WITNESSES OF
THE- BOTH OF YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. MADAM CHAIR AND MOST
DISTINGUISHED AUDIBLE MEMBERS
MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF OF KEEP
CELL ANTENNAS AWAY. THIS BILL
IS ANOTHER UNNECESSARY GIVEAWAY
TO INDUSTRY AT THE EXPENSE OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT IS A
SUBSIDY EVERY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CURRENTLY CAN CHOOSE THE MANNER
OF INSTALLING A SUBSURFACE PIPE
OR CONDUIT FOR FIBER OPTIC
CABLES. THAT IS GOOD THE SYSTEM
IS CURRENTLY WORKING WHILE THE
BILL HAS NOT IDENTIFIED ANY
PROBLEM IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED IN
GENERAL ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTIONS ARE NOT A GOOD IDEA
AND DO NOT WORK WELL. DO YOU
KNOW WHAT MICRO TRENCHING AS-
THERE'S A DEFINITION IN THIS
BILL BUT IT DOES NOT TELL YOU.
IT'S DIGGING UP THE STREET
LITERALLY. IMAGINE MILES AND
MILES OF STREET IN EVERY CITY
DOG UP AND ALL THE PROBLEMS
THAT WILL CREATE. THE BILL SAYS
NOTHING ABOUT RESTORING THE
CONDITION OF THE STREET TO ITS
ORIGINAL CONDITION ONCE THE
MICROPHONE AND HIS DOG AND THE
CONDUIT IS PLACED. IT SHOULD
FURTHER THE CARRIERS MUST BE
REQUIRED TO PAY FOR SUCH
RESTORATION OTHERWISE THE BILL
IS A HUGE UNFUNDED MANDATE
FORCING THE CITIES TO PAY FOR.
THE BILL SAYS MICHAEL FRENCH
MEANS A NARAL OPEN EXCAVATION
TRENCH. YOU SHOULD NOT ALLOW
ANY OKAY OPEN EXCAVATION TRENCH
UNLESS THE CITY CHOOSES IT WHAT
CROWN CASTLE'S TRYING TO SELL
YOU IS THE CHEAPEST WAY BUT NOT
THE BEST. A MUCH BETTER WAY TO
INSTALL CONDUIT IS MENTIONED IN
THE BILL BORING A TUNNEL.
BORING IS THE INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICE. BORING DOES NOT TEAR
UP THE STREET. BORING INVOLVED
SENDING A DIGGING TOOL INTO THE
GROUND THEY CAN BE GUIDED
REMOTELY CAN TURN LEFT RIGHT UP
OR DOWN CAN GO AS FAR
UNDERGROUND AS YOU WANTED TO.
AND COME UP OUT OF THE GROUND
WHERE YOU WANTED TO. THIS IS A
FAR SUPERIOR PRACTICE THIS IS
WHAT CITIES WANT IT IS NOT
TERRIBLE ST OR REQUIRE
RESTORATION OTHER THAN. AT THE
ENTRY POINT AND EXIT POINT. YOU
CAN BORE TUNNEL IN THE EASEMENT
THE. PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY ACROSS
FRONT YARDS. YOU ALSO INSTALL
OPTIC CABLES ABOVE GROUND.
SONIC DOT NET IS A PROVIDER
THAT'S GIVING THE SERVICE ONE
GIGABYTE SPEED UP AND ONE
GIGABYTE DOWN FOR FIFTY DOLLARS
A MONTH. THE FIBER OPTIC CABLES
GO ABOVE GROUND AND THEY RUN
ACROSS UTILITY POLES. IN THE
CITIES OF PETALUMA SANTA ROSA
AND ALAMEDA AMONG OTHERS. THAT
IS A CURRENT REAL WORLD EXAMPLE
IN THE STATE SHOULD FOLLOW
WHAT. DID YOU ASK THE CITY'S
WHAT TYPE OF FIBER INSTALLATION
THEY PREFER. WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO DO IN THIS BILL IS YOU'RE
GOING TO RUSH YOU'RE GOING TO
PREEMPT INTELLIGENT LOCAL
PLANNING AND END UP WITH
INFERIOR INSTALLATION OF
CONDUIT. THE BILL SAYS THE
INSTALLATION OF FIBER IS NOT A
MUNICIPAL AFFAIR AS THAT TERM
IS USED IN SECTION FIVE.
ARTICLE ELEVEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHY IS
THIS NOT A MUNICIPAL AFFAIRS.
THERE'S NO REASON STATED FOR
THAT. IT'S AN ARBITRARY
DECISION. HAS THIS BEEN TRIED
ANYWHERE. HAS IT WORKED. YOU
SHOULD NOT MAKE A STATE POLICY
ON SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN
TRIED EXTENSIVELY AND WORKED
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS.
THERE WAS NOT ONE EXAMPLE OF
WHERE THAT HAS BEEN DONE WITH
MY TEAM. WITH I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE OUR OTHER SPEAKER
PLEASE THEN THAT WOULD BE
MISTER MCGAVIN. THANK OU CHAIR
AGUIAR-CURRY AND THE ESTEEMED
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I'M
GOING TO TELL YOU THAT I AM AN
EXPERT IN MEASURING AND
MITIGATING MICROWAVE RADIATION
THERE WAS NO OTHER EXPERT IN
THE ROOM HERE YOU ASKED AN
ATTORNEY RUDY RAMOS FOR SOME
KIND OF TECHNICAL EXPLANATION
MR VOEPEL. LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHAT THE
SPIN THE ANSWERS REALLY ARE
BECAUSE YOU WERE MISLED BY HIM
OKAY. LOOK THE TRIPLE THREAT
SIX SEVEN EIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE
BILLS DESTROYED LOCAL CONTROL
OVER BOTH FIBER OPTIC
INSTALLATIONS WIRED'S
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S FIVE FIVE
SIX FIVE THREE SEVEN THIS ONE
AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT. WELL
NEARLY FOUR MILLION ELECTRONIC
DATA SETS OF CALIFORNIANS OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND WORKERS OF CW A
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED CITIES
OPPOSE THESE BILLS WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT IS REALLY GOING
ON HERE. THE ACTUAL AUTHORS OF
THESE BILLS ARE THE AMERICAN
LEGISLATIVE EXCHANGE COUNCIL
THE CTIA THE LOBBYIST FOR CROWN
CASTLE EIGHTEEN PM VERIZON. WHO
ARE ATTEMPTING A MULLIGAN A DO
OVER A REPEAT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEENS VETOED SB SIX FOUR
NINE. THIRTY RACES AN ATTORNEY.
EXCUSE ARE YOU EXPERT EXCUSE ME
PLEASE KEEP ON THE TOPIC OF AND
I AM ABSOLUTELY. THE BILL
LEADING THE YOU'RE NOT SHE TO
GO TO OF THE ISSUES THIS WILL
BE VERY MATERIAL TO THE JUDGES
WHO ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
REVIEWING THESE BILLS DUE TO
THE DUE PROCESS THERE IS THAT
ARE WELL DOCUMENTED ON AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN ON APRIL TWENTIETH
TO MAY NINETEENTH. AND TODAY
WITH THESE BILLS ON JUNE NINTH.
LISTEN WHAT DO WE HAVE WE HAVE
THESE THREE BILLS AS THE
CENTURY SB SIX WERE NOT ON
STEROIDS WRAPPED UP IN A
BACKWARDS LOOKING COVE IT
NINETEEN PAT TINA AND I SHARED
OF DIGITAL DIVIDE LIPSTICK
APPLY TO THIS COLLECTIVE PIG.
THESE BILLS ARE ACTUALLY JUST
INJUSTICE AND TYRANNY THAT WILL
FURTHER ENRICH MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR WIRES COMPANIES AT THE
EXPENSE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
PRIVACY QUITE ENJOY MYSTERIES
2230% PROPERTY VALUE LOSSES FOR
RESIDENTS A BUSINESS IS.
CLOSEST TO THE SO CALLED SMALL
CELLS IN THE WORDS OF THE LATE
GREAT YOGI BERRA THIS IS A DEJA
VU ALL OVER AGAIN WE DID THIS
FOR YEARS AGO AND THE BILL WAS
MERCIFULLY VETOED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN WHO WROTE I BELIEVE THE
INTEREST WITH THE COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN MANAGING THE RIGHTS OF
WAY. REQUIRES A MORE BALANCED
SOLUTION THAN THE ONE ACHIEVED
IN THIS BILL THAT WOULD APPLY
TO ALL OF THESE BILLS AS WELL.
THE BEST SOLUTION TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS TO INSTALL
FIBER OPTICS TO THE PREMISES
AND THEN PROVIDE PUBLIC ACCESS
TO ALL OF THE FIBER OPTIC
CABLES THAT ARE IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHTS OF WAY THAT'S THE KEY
POINT. YOU CANNOT ALLOW PRIVATE
COMPANIES TO PUT PUT FIBER IN
THE PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY
WITHOUT PUBLIC ACCESS TO IT.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM HERE ALLOW
THE PUBLIC TO HOOK UP TO THE
FIBER OPTIC GOODNESS ALLOW THEM
TO GET THIS DIRECTLY TO THEIR
HOMES AND NOW YOU HAVE SOLVED
THE PROBLEM PLEASE LOOK AT
THESE POLLS THEY MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE. THAT'S MY SERVICE I HAVE
THE FROM SONIC DOT NET IT'S
AWESOME. SO WHAT DO YOU NEED
ANY TITLE TO REGULATED PRICING
IN ORDER. VICE I'M SORRY WE
CLOSE. AND ALL I'M SAYING TO
YOU HERE'S PLEASE UNDERSTAND
THAT FIVE G. AND FOUR G. OR
MARKETING LABELS THEY GO FROM
SIX HUNDRED MEGAHERTZ THE
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED MEGAHERTZ
THE SAME FEQUENCIES AS WIFI
SIR AND SO. THEY DO GO THROUGH
WALLS THEY GO THROUGH
EVERYTHING THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED.
ISN'T GOING ACTUALLY PUT. THE
FOR THEIR FIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
LINE FIRST OF ALL WE WILL DO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY AGAIN. THIS IS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
THANK YOU. OPERATOR. AT NINE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
OUT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL GUNNING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUST MY
REFUSAL COME BY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY NINETY FOUR HAD. I
DON'T WANT. TO NINE- TWENTY ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MY ELAINE WITTY
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN I'M SURE MEMBERS WORK IN
GOLD EVERYTHING A WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR OUR STORIES FROM THE
FRONT LINES AND MARKETABLE
ABSOLUTELY FORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU RIGHT THREE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MELANIE FIGUEROA ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BRING THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THEY'RE A LITTLE OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SURE I HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENTING HERE TO JUST BE ONE
MOMENT THAT Y. NUMBER.
AND LIKE
THREE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GEN YES MY NAME IS
CAROLINE STAPLETON ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OPERATORS THAT THE LAST OF THE
IN SUPPORT. CORRECT I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU WHEN
WE MOVE INTO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION JUST AS A REMINDER
YOUR NAME. YOUR OF PHILLY YEAH
SHE OR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO ACT THE THREE
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO THREE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE MEMBERS PATHOLOGY DOCTOR
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T WANT STRIVE.FOR
HELLO HOW GREAT HI MY NAME'S
AND HONEST TEACHER AT SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WON SEVENTY EIGHT
SEATS CAR HAD. ONE ONE SEVEN
EIGHT. B. THREE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JOHANNA DANNY I REPRESENT THE
NEVADA CUNTY PUBLIC WORKING
GROUP FOR SAFE TECHNOLOGY AND
WE OPPOSE SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RANGERS
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWO THREE SIX. HELLO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CONSTANCE
ANDERSON. AS A MEMBER OF. I
READ THIS. AND A PERSON FEDERAL
DISABILITY DUE TO SEVERE
MICROWAVE SICKNESS I'VE ONLY OF.
WILL BE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO-
TO PLEASE CALL ATTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FALCONS ALL
THIS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA CLARITA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NINO LEYVA WE
HAVE CITY COUNCIL OKAY AND
RESPECTFUL OF CONSTRUCTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE CALL I HAVE-
ONE ONE FIVE THREE. ERIN BURNED
MULTIPLICATIONS. UPLOAD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL ADDED. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN MY NAME IS
ALLAN PARK. I'M JUST BROKE THE
CITY OF A LOT. FINALLY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
COOKING FROM WALNUT CREEK- THE
TEACHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALL SINCE BURGER OF NEVADA
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
HAD CHIU FROM GARDEN GROVE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT.
NINE ZERO. NINE THREE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
AUGUST PRICE PROTECT WELLNESS
THEIR BEEN DOZENS OF PEER
REVIEWED RESEARCH STUDIES
PROVING THAT WIRELESS ENERGY
HAS A BIOLOGICAL IMPACT I URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO HAVE YOUR
STAFFERS. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ENGINE. NINE ONE TWO NINE.
HELLO HELLO I HAD. HELLO YES MY
NAME IS MARCY GALLAGHER MALL
CALLING PREVENT SOUTH BAY IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO Q. S. B. EIGHT NINE
NINE THREE THREE AS FAR AS- YOU
SENT ME YES. YES ALL MY GOSH
OKAY- YES LIST BEARS I'M THE
ONE THAT SPOKE BEFORE SAYING
THAT PEOPLE WERE GOING TO BE
GIVEN THEIR NUMBERS IN ORDER TO
OPPOSE SO YOU KNOW THAT'S A
VIOLATION OF AS WE CAN ACT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BUT I REPRESENT
A FEW THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE-
WEST LA ACTUALLY IN L. A.
COUNTY AND WE ALL POST PEOPLE'S
INITIATIVE .ORG AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE YOU THREE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GLAD. YES DAVID
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF STOP FIVE
G. CARLSBAD I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS IS RIDICULOUS. THANK YOU.
HEARING TO AWAIT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GENTLE THUNDER THE ALBUM
OUT SHASTA AND SISKIYOU COUNTY
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY. NINETY FOUR. BY
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE SEVEN EIGHT.
NINE THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL ATTY. THOMAS FROM WIRED
WIRELESS EDUCATION. WIRELESS
RADIATION EDUCATION AND DEFENSE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT NINETEENTH
PLEASE GO OUT. NINE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHO WILL
MOVE ON FOR QUESTIONS OF THE
FROM THE COMMITTEE. FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. SING YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HARD WORK.
BOERNER HORVATH I GET A BETTER-
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD YOU KNOW SO
MUCH YOU KNOW IN OUR CITY SO
MANY OF OUR ROADS ARE DAMAGED
BY THE POPE OPEN TRENCH
TECHNOLOGY AND AS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ADVANCING- ARE
CONNECTIVE ITTY AND OUR
CHANGING WORLD I THINK MY TO GO
TRENCHING AND HAVING A SET
POLICY FOR MICRO TRENCHING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. REALLY
CREATES THE CERTAINTY OF CITIES
AND SAW YOU KNOW PROVIDERS NEED
TO IN ORDER TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING HOME FOR YOURSELF I
THINK WE MOVED IN SECONDS YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
WE HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST THE SECOND MY
BURNER HARBAUGH- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I JUST WANNA SAY I
THINK YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HER KIND WORDS- AND
WILL SAY THAT THIS AGAIN WILL
CREATE LOW IMPACT VERY LESS LOW
INVASIVE- OPPORTUNITIES TO
DEPLOY BROADBAND FOR MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND LASTLY THIS
HAS NOTHING RESPECTFULLY TO DO
WITH FIVE G. THIS IS FIBER
OPTICS- MICROCHIP JING SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RESPECT THE
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR BRING IN
THE BILL FOR IT- DOES WITH THIS
PREVIOUS BILL WE'VE HAD EACH OF
US IS PURSUING DIFFERENT
AVENUES FOR EXPANDING BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND YOUR BILL IS
DOES IS IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
GETTING THAT DONE I WILL BE
VOTING I FOR YOUR BILL TODAY
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMUNICATION
THE CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. AGUIAR-CURRY
IRAQI HI LACKEY I BLOOM BLOOM.
I REMEMBER THAT I PROBLEMS FOR
ALMOST AYE THREE OF US IS
RIVERSIDE ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT I
WILL TELL I FELT BY EIGHT ZERO
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO ZERO AND
SOMETHING YOU HAVE MISSING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE ARE NOW
LOOKING FOR A AND OFTEN-
SENATOR. TROUBLES WE HAVE THIS
AFTERNOON- PRESENTING FOR US.
THE SENATOR MIKE MCGUIRE- FOR
SENATOR OF SECONDS. START WHEN
YOU'RE READY WE KNOW IT'S A BIG
RUSH DOWN THE STAIRS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR I'M
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE I PRESENT
TíNH ON BEHALF OF PROTEIN TONI
ATKINS IT'S AN HONOR TO BE WITH
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND TO EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU- TO MADAM CHAIR INTO HER
AMAZING STAFF TEAM FOR ALL OF
THE NOW SYSTEM WORK ON THIS
BILL IN ALWAYS GRATEFUL TO WORK
WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR MANY OF YOU I THIS
BILL WILL LOOK REALLY FAMILIAR
OF THE PROTEIN DID AUTHOR I.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY LAST
YEAR. WE TOOK A GOOD BILL THAT
MET THE FATE OF A HARD DEADLINE
AND AFTER LISTENING TO REALLY
CRITICAL FEEDBACK FROM
HOMEOWNERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE
IMPROVED. NOW SB NINE PROMOTES
SMALL SCALE SMALL SCALE
NEIGHBORHOOD DRIVEN RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS. IT STREAMLINES
THE PROCESS FOR A HOMEOWNER TO
CREATE A DUPLEXER SURVIVE
SUBDIVIDE IN EXISTING LOT IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS UP TO FOUR
UNITS NOT TO EXCEED FOUR UNITS.
SB NINE STRIKES AN APPROPRIATE
BALANCE THAT APPROPRIATE
BALANCE BETWEEN RESPECTING
LOCAL CONTROL IN CREATING THE
ENVIRONMENT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE PRODUCTION OF SMALL SCALE.
NEIGHBORHOOD DEVELOPMENT THAT
WE SO BADLY NEED TO BE A
CONTACT THEIR HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE PANDEMIC HAS
MADE THAT HOUSING CRISIS EVEN
WORSE WE NEED ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND HOMES EACH AND
EVERY YEAR FOR DEVELOPING ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND AND IN THE LA
REGION ALONE OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. THE LA REGION NEEDS
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE FOUR
MILLION HOUSING UNITS. NOW ONE
MODIFICATION- IN THE BILL THIS
YEAR. IT THAT THE BILL PROVIDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE AUTHORITY
TO BE ABLE TO ENACT AN OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS. WE'VE
HEARD THAT LOUD AND CLEAR WHICH
IS WHY PRO TO MACINNES ADVANCE
THAT AMENDMENT AND IT IS DOWN
THE BILL. ANOTHER AMENDMENT
MADE CLEAR AT THE NUMBER OF
UNITS ALLOWED. IN AT THE RISK
MADAM CHAIR OF SOUNDING LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN. UP TO FOUR UNITS ARE
ALLOWED NOT TO EXCEED THOSE FOR
UNITS. I NOT FIVE NOT SIX FOUR.
NOW YOU CAN'T DOUBLE DIP WITH
THIS BILL. IF YOU CURRENTLY
HAVE A SINGLE FAMILY HOME BY JD
U. N. EIGHTY YOU YOU CAN'T PUT
ANOTHER FOUR UNITS ON. THE
PROPERTY YOU CAN ONLY DO THOSE
THREE YOU CAN'T PUT ANOTHER
FOUR ON THERE. NOW THIS BILL IS
ALSO OPTIONAL FOR HOMEOWNERS.
THIS BILL MERELY OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR HOMEOWNERS TO
ADVANCE WORK FORCE HOUSING. AND
I'D LIKE TO SAY TO SOME WHO
ARGUE THAT THIS COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE LOOK OF IN FEEL
OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD- IF WE LOOK
AROUND US. THERE ARE ALREADY
BEAUTIFUL DUPLEXES AND EIGHTY
USE NEXT ORDER TRADITIONAL
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND IN SOME
OF OUR STATE'S MOST SOUGHT
AFTER ZIP CODES THEY'VE ALREADY
ADVANCED. THIS TYPE OF LOCAL
LAW. EITHER CHARMING HOUSES AND
THEY'RE NOT ONLY A BRIGHT SPOT
ON THE BLOCK FOR JUST ONE
FAMILY. BUT ALSO COMFORTABLE
PLACE FOR TWO FAMILIES TO BE
ABLE TO CALL HOME. ALONG WITH
THE SAFEGUARDS IN THIS BILL I'D
LIKE TO VERY QUICKLY MADAM
CHAIR I IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU
DISCUSS THE OPPORTUNITY THIS
BILL PROVIDES. FAMILIES AND
SENIORS TO HAVE MORE OPTIONS TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD MULTI
GENERATIONAL HOUSING AND BUILD
MULTI GENERATIONAL WEALTH.
INTERGENDER WEALTH REALLY IS A
CURRENCY THAT WE KNOW IS
CRUCIAL TO COUNTERING INEQUITY.
IN CREATING MORE SOCIAL
MOBILITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ESPECIALLY NEIGHBORHOODS WERE
OUTDATED ZONING LAWS HAVE
CREATED BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. IN OF LEAD TO
OVERCROWDING. NOW THIS
LEGISLATION PROVIDES HOMEOWNERS
WITH OPTIONS TO PROVIDE. REAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING
FAMILIES WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
TO FIND A HOME IN THEIR PRICE
RANGE OR WHO MAY BE LOOKING FOR
THEIR OWN PATH TO MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP. IT
ALSO PROVIDES A CHANCE FOR
ADULT KIDS. TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD A HOME IN THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY GREW UP THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. ERIC AND I
REALLY STRUGGLED WITH OR TO
HAVE AN AGING PAENT LIVE NEXT
DOOR TO YOU. THIS BILL IS AN
EXPANSION OF. OPPORTUNITIES
THAT CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERYONE HOMEOWNERS RENTERS AS
WELL AS FAMILIES ALIKE. NOW
THIS HOUSING CRISIS IS SO
<c.green>OMPLEX IN LARGE. THERE'S NOT</c>
GOING TO BE A SINGLE SOLUTION
OR SILVER BULLET TO SOLVE IT
OVERNIGHT. BUT SB NINE IT'S A
CRITICAL PIECE TO OUR HOUSING
PUZZLE. THE BILL CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE.
PROGRESSIVE AND POSITIVE CHANGE
ANDSTRENGTHENS THE FABRIC OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS WITH EQUITY.
INCLUSIVITY AS WELL AS
AFFORDABILITY. MEDICARE WE HAVE
TO LEAD WITNESSES IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU. TAMI NEUMANN
WITH UNITED WAY OLE. ALONG WITH
LAUREN DAVID LYNCH YET SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. AT THE
MOST APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR WILL OPERATOR
WE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK WITH
TAMI NEUMANN. OR LEARN DEVELOP
VALENCIA. IS SANCHEZ. YOU THE
ONE THAT'S ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU. BOTH LINES ARE OPEN THANK
YOU TOM THURMOND HERE AND READY
TO GO GOOD AFTERNOON. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME MY NAME IS TOMMY NEWMAN AND
I HELPED- LEAD OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS WORK HERE AT THE
UNITED WAY OF GREATER A LACK.
AND WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT PRESS. WE KNOW
THAT PLANETS POLICIES
ESPECIALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AFTER IT AND RACIAL
SEGREGATION. WELL DISPARITIES
FOR. IT IN L. A. COUNTY.
EXACTLY AND YES. THAT THE
AFRICAN. WHITE FAMILY AND
ASSISTED. WE KNOW THAT. I RIGHT
THE COLOR DISPROPORTIONATELY-
BUT SB. INCREASED ACT THAT OUT
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT COURT
AGREED WITH BLACK FROM. I HAVE
GREAT. NEWS. WHITE HOUSE BLACK
OR IS HE ME MISS NIGHT WITH A
MISTER NEWMAN- WOULD YOU BE
ABLE CALL BACK IN WEEK HEAR
TEST. AND I KNOW SOME- IT'S CAN
GIVING A BACK PART OF THOSE TWO
PHONES ON THE SAME TIME-
OPERATOR CAN YOU Q. HIM UP TO
COME BACK AND WE'LL GO AHEAD
WITH LAUREN AND WILL COME BACK
TO TOMMY. PLEASE IS THAT OKAY
WITH YOU CENTER THAT'S GREAT NO
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND AGREE
THANK YOU OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
ENABLING YEAH REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO JOIN SENATE PRO TEM
ACTIONS AND STATE SENATOR
MCGUIRE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCEPTABILITY CONTINUE TO BE
AMONG CALIFORNIA'S MOST
PRESSING ISSUES. ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE MANY CAUSES OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS SOME OF
WHICH PLANNERS HAVE CREATED YOU
PLAY A PART. UNDER CURRENT LAW
A MAJORITY OF RESIDENTIAL AREAS
CAN ONLY BE USED FOR SINGLE
FAMILY DWELLING. LIMIT HOUSING
SUPPLY AND EXCLUDES LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FROM HOUSING
WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
MINORITY COMMUNITIES. WE
BELIEVE THAT SB NINE CAN BE
PART OF AN EFFORT TO EXPAND
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERYONE. SB NINE DOES NOT
PROHIBIT SINGLE FAMILY HOME OR
DOWNEY ASSEMBLY PROVIDE BUT IN
SUCH AREAS PROPERTY OWNERS MUST
ALSO BE ALLOWED TO CREATE SMALL
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING OPTIONS.
SB NINE CREATES A BY RIGHT
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR THE CREATION OF TWO TO FOUR
HOMES AND SINGLE FAMILY ITSELF.
IT ALLOWS PERSONAL MAPS TO
CREATE TWO LOT TERM ONE AND
PERMITS UP AT MOM A LOT. YOU
ARE AT. TO UNITS EACH FACT THAT.
AB A LOT ALREADY ALLOW THE CAR
REQUIRES ALREADY ALLOWS UP
THREE IN A HELLO. SO THIS
REALLY ISN'T. CHANGE BUT THE
KEY IS THE PERSONAL MATTER.
ALLOW NEW HOME TO BE WHICH HELP
CREE HARMONY OP. NOT AND THEY
UNDER OTHER HOUSE PRODUCTION
BILLS. AND ALTHOUGH THE
APPROVAL. IS MINISTERIAL THE
MAJORITY OF OBJECTIVE MANY
STANDARDS WILL STILL CONTINUE
TO APPLY TO NEW DEVELOPMENT.
BUT THERE'S A SECRET EXEMPTION
TO ACCELERATE THE ADOPTION OF
NEW EMPLOYMENT REGULATIONS.
THIS APPROACH HELPS BALANCE THE
STATE AND LOCAL INTERESTS SB
NINE DEFINES MINIMUM
PERFORMANCE TARGETS BUT IT
LEAVES ROOM FOR LOCAL PLANNERS
TO DEFINE AND APPLY CONTACT.
THE CIVIC CENTER. FIND OUR HOPE
IS THAT INCREASING HOUSING TO
NOTHING FAMILY. WILL MAKE.
COMMUNITIES MARK THIS BUT WE
ALSO THAT NOT COME AT THE COST
OF YOUR- FIFTEEN HEARD. THAT'S
WHY WE SUPPORT THE BILL STATE
TO PREVENT A LOT OF EXIT HOUSE
AND THE- DISPLACEMENT OF
HONORABLE. AT CALIFORNIA.
DOWNING REFORM END FACTORS OF
REQUIRING ONLY SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES ON THE MAJORITY OF
RESIDENTIAL LAND. WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SB NINE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR CAN WE SEE. IF WE
CAN GET MISTER NEWMAN BACK ON.
THANK YOU. IN OUR- THE LOWER
CAPE FEAR. MANAGER BACK WITH
THAT THANK YOU MISTER NEWMAN
WHAT YOU START OF. BOCANEGRA I
DO HAVE A BIT OF AN ACT ON ONLY
THAN ONE THOUGHT I PROMISE. THE.
BUT AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
HOW'S THAT THAT'S BETTER AT
LEAST THAT'S MUCH BETTER. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME IS TOMMY EVAN
AND I HOPE TO BE A HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS WORK AT THE UNITED
WAY OF GREATER LA- TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT. ALL ESPECIALLY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE
DRIVEN RACIAL SEGREGATION AND
WEALTH DISPARITIES FOR DECADES
IN L. A. COUNTY THE AVERAGE
BLACK FAMILY HAS ONE NINETY OF
THE WEALTH OF THE AVERAGE WHITE
FAMILY HAS AND THE SHAMEFUL WE
KNOW THAT OUR HOUSING CRISIS IS
DRIVING OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AND THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING
THE BURDEN. SB NINE WILL HELP
TO INCREASE ACCESS. TO HOUSING
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES IN A
DRIVEN THE DISPARITIES BETWEEN
WHITE HOUSEHOLDS AND BLACK AND
BROWN HOUSEHOLD. I DO NOT
EXPECT THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN RESPECTING LOCAL
CONTROL INCLUDING THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR SMALL SCALE
NEIGHBORHOOD DEVELOPMENT TO
BENEFIT THE BROADER COMMUNITY.
OF COURSE HAVE BEEN AND WILL
NOT FALL OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS ON ITS OWN
AND WE MUST CONTINUE TO PUSH
FORWARD ON ALL FRONTS.
INCLUDING RENTER PROTECTIONS AN
INCREASE IN PUBLIC FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT HOUSING
FOR WORKING AMERICAN PEOPLE.
UNITED WAY OF GREATER LA STANDS
WHAT LEADERS WERE WILLING TO
REJECT THE STATUS QUO AND
VISION A FUTURE WHERE EVERYONE
IN CALIFORNIA HAS A SAFE AND
STABLE HOME WITH THE ABILITY TO
THRIVE. THANK YOU TO A PART
TIME ACTION FOR THE COURAGE TO
INTRODUCE A MOVE THIS BILL AND
THANK EACH OF YOU WHO IS
WILLING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
AND IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
MISTER NEWMAN WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE TO IN A POSITION ONE IS
RAN MARTIN. I BELIEVE HIM FROM
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION.
WHO'S HERE I BELIEVE. AS WELL
AS WE HAVE BOB BLOCK OF
PACHINKO. MAYOR PRO TEM
CONCEIVED DOWNEY WIL BE ON THE
PHONE SO MISTER MARTIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION- WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THERE IS A
HOUSING CRISIS HERE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE VERY DEEP
CONCERN. WHAT WITH THIS BILL
AND MANY OF THE BILLS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED IS THE LACK OF
ATTENTION IS BEING PAYS TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST CHALLENGED
BY THIS HOUSING CRISIS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXTREMELY LOW
VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BELOW FIFTY PERCENT. OF
THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME- AND WE
NEED TO PAY MORE ATTENTION TO
THOSE PEOPLE IF WE'RE GOING TO
RESOLVE WHERE THE PROBLEM
REALLY LIES- DOES STUDY THAT
CAME OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO.
INDICATES THAT THE MIDDLE- THE
MODERATE INCOME FOLKS IN ABOVE
MODERATE INCOME BOOKS IS NOT
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE LOWEST
INCOME. I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT. A PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL
IN TERMS OF THE KINDS OF
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT DEVELOPERS
AND OTHERS WILL GO INTO IN
ORDER TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
AND IT IS THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT ARE MORE LOW INCOME WITH-
WITH THE HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR
WHO WHO HAVE ACHIEVED SOME OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM- WITH
HOMEOWNERSHIP- WILL BE A WILL
BE. COERCED OR CAJOLED OR BOT
OUT OF THOSE- AND FORCED TO
MOVE TO PLACES WHERE THEY CAN
NO LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE- AND
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED OR
AT LEAST. ARE PROVIDED SOME-
SOME PROTECTIONS AS THEY LEAVE
LEAVE THOSE HOMES- WITH RENTAL
ASSISTANCE RENTAL RELOCATION
AND THINGS LIKE THAT- THE THIRD
THING I WANT TO POINT OUT IS
THE BILL DOES INCLUDE SOME
PROTECTIONS- RELATIVE TO RENT
CONTROLLED OR RENT RESTRICTED
PROPERTIES. THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THOSE PROTECTIONS APPLY TO-
RENTAL UNITS APARTMENTS
ETCETERA IT DOES NOT APPLY TO
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES COSTA
HAWKINS- RENTAL ACT A RENTAL
HOUSING ACT DOES NOT INCLUDE
SMALL- SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND
SO THE PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN
THE BILL. ACTUALLY DON'T EXIST-
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO ARE
IN THIS BILL I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT AS A MATTER OF PERFECT.
PERFECT TIMING THE ARTICLE ON
THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
SACRAMENTO BEE THIS MORNING-
THE TALKS ABOUT THE LACK OF
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE MADE
COLLECTIVELY AND- OF DEAL. WITH
THIS- I THINK THE PROGRESS CAN
BE MADE IF ALL OF US
COLLECTIVELY WILL WORK TOWARDS.
FINDING THE SOLUTIONS THAT
AFFECT THE- THE LARGEST NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THE PEOPLE HO ARE
MOST IMPACTED BY BY THIS
CRISIS. AND NOT CREATE
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS- BY GOING
INTO INTO EXISTING
NEIGHBORHOODS OF LOW INCOME
PEOPLE- AND CREATING A
SITUATION WHERE THEY CAN NO
LONGER LIVE THERE. WE THANK YOU
UP FOR THAT TIM AND I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MARTIN
WILL GO TO BLOCK A PACHINKO. ON
THE PHONE PLEASE. I'M NOT SURE
THIS IS IT JUST LIABILITY
CALIFORNIA CITY UNFORTUNATELY-
MAYOR PRO TEMP CZECHO HAD TO
LEAVE AT THREE PM TO CHAIRED
MEDIA PER CITY I DISAGREE WITH
YOUR MANAGER MAY I PRESENT THIS
CITY'S PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
ISSUE. NOT BE FINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- YOU KNOW CHRIS
WALLACE TO BEGIN BUT YOU'RE
THINKING FEDERAL WIRED WAS
PRESENTATION AND CENTER PRO
ATKINS. PRAMAC INSERT FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH HER AND HER
STAFF AND APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
MEETINGS WITH THAT-
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO COME TO RESOLUTIONS ON
SEVERAL PRIMARY CONCERNS WITH
THE MEASURE- HAVE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY STATED- SB NINE
WOULD REQUIRE CITIES TO
MINISTERIAL APPROVED- LOCKS
PUT. AND ALSO THE CREATION OF
TWO RESIDENTIAL UNITS ON EACH
LOT- WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL I MEAN
THAT MEANS WITHOUT CONDITION
WITHOUT DISCRETION NO PUBLIC
INPUT. AND NO SEE WHAT- WHAT WE
FEEL AS THOUGH THAT THAT
PROCESS IS NEEDED- WE CERTAINLY
CAN ALL AGREE THAT THERE IS A
HOUSING CRISIS YOU HEARD FROM
US AT THE LEAGUE CALIFORNIA
CITIES ARE FOR WELL OVER. YOU
KNOW COUPLE YEARS NOW
ADVOCATING IN SUPPORT OF MANY
THE PEOPLE THAT HELPS FOR
HELPING CONSTRUCTION. AND OF
COURSE YOU HAD DISAGREEMENTS ON
HOW BEST TO DO THAT. BUT AGAIN
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT THERE IS
A HOUSING CRISIS AND WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
UNFORTUNATELY SB NINE WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS NOT THE APPROPRIATE
APPROACH THAN IT DOES- YOU KNOW
DISREGARD THAT COMMUNITY BASED
APPROACH. THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT ALL OF
OUR CITIES ARE CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING THE UPDATE TO THEIR
HOUSE YOU KNOW MEANT RIGHT NOW.
THE END OF THE LITTLE OVER A
YEAR WE'RE GONNA GET A FIVE
MORE THAN TWO MILLION SITES.
FOR ADDITIONAL HOUSING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THOSE SITES WILL BE
READY AND FOR DEVELOPMENT IS
ONLY WILL BE CONSISTENT SHORTLY
THEREAFTER. SO DEVELOPERS WILL
BE ABLE TO CHOOSE FROM MORE
THAN TWO MILLION LOCATIONS FOR
SITE FOR HOUSING TO BE
CONSTRUCTED MORE THAN THOSE
UNITS BE AVAILABLE. SB NINE
UNFORTUNATELY DISREGARDS THAT
PROCESS INSTEAD CITIES EVEN
THOUGH YOU'VE GOT YOUR HOUSING
ELEMENT CERTIFIED EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE CALLING THE PLANT THEM
ALL OF THE STATE. YOU WILL NEED
TO ALLOW FOR MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL AND THE CREATION OF
ADDITIONAL DENSITY IN YOUR
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS. NO
MATTER WHAT THE AGREEMENT HAS
BEEN WITH YOUR COMMUNITIES. BUT
THAT MANAGER- WE RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR NO VOTE ON THIS BY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING TODAY ALSO- WE
WILL NOW GO TO- ONLINE TO
WITNESS IN SOME. YOUR STATE
YOUR NAY YOUR YOU ON THE BILL-ONLY WE WILL ALLOW THE MATH OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE
FIFTEEN FOR THE OPPOSITION
FIFTEEN FOR THE SUPPORT- AND WE
WILL NOW TAKE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR FIRST I'LL
TAKE THOSE HERE IN THE- IN THE
AUDITORIUM. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THANK YOU. ALEX TOWARDS A
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION AS WELL AS THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN THE
AUDITORIUM. SEEING NONE OF WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES PLEASE
OPERATOR AGAIN WELL AS FOR THE
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF STATE
THEIR NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION
IN THE POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. NINE THAT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF
YOU NEED TO REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM THIS QUEUE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN. WE HAVE ABOUT FORTY
FIVE IN Q. OR TO Y. NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT NINE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
THREE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JUST HIRE PEOPLE COME OUT OF
READERSHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT SIX
FIVE. HELLO JERRY YAK BUILDING
GHILJI COUNCILMEMBER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVENING
BECAUSE BACK BOWLING
REPRESENTING- YOU CAN BE ACTION
EAST BAY N. B. AND ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HONORABLE
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THINKING
HINDSIGHT BECAUSE WHILE
CATCHING FAULTING REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
pSUPPORT IT'S AMENDED POSITION
ON SB NINE ARE INTERESTED IN
THE- THANK YOU RYAN THREE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
AN APPLICATION I MADE IN THE
WRONG. THANK YOU OVER TO TRYING
TO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M ALSO IN OPPOSITION. TRYING
TO SEVENTEEN THREE OF YOUR AT.
HI IS THERE A BOOK WINTERTON
CITY OF CAMPBELL REPRESENTING
STOPPING IN THE IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT WILL
BE- FERRARI ON BEHALF OF
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MATTHEW LEWIS A HOMEOWNER
REPRESENTING SOUTH BERKELEY NOW
COALITION OF HOMEOWNERS AND
RENTERS IN BERKELEY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY THREE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE PHILADELPHIA
CRANK CALLING ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GLAD. I'M IN
OPPOSITION AND I WILL CONTACT.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY THIS IS
KELLY CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
DAIRY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE NOT A NOT LIKE A
PUBLIC AFFAIR CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING ORGANISATIONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT ON CALIFORNIA
YIMBY HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA AT THE COUNCIL OF
INFILL BUILDERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION ABUNDANT
HOUSING LA TMG PARTNERS THE
COMPUTER COLLECTION UNITED WAY
BAY AREA HOUSING TRUST SILICON
VALLEY. YEAH A AS WELL AS- THE
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION. ALL IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO SIXTEEN PLEASE GO OUT.
HI MY NAME IS TRACY MILLER
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AT THE END OF
VALUE IN BEING SPECIFICALLY
DENNIS BOYD SANG AND PRAYED
THAT THE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M DAVID
WALKER NUMBER OF NON UNION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE TRUCK
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF SECOND
AMERICAN ALL SPAM BURKE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
RYAN TO FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS BABY. CALLING
FROM UNION CITY AIM THEM
DISTRICT TWENTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BRING
THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A- NOISE FROM
CAMPUS THE CARE YOU NEED WHEN
YOU CALL AND JOHN COURT AT
NIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT SIXTY FOUR PLEASE FOR AT.
CHECKED YOUR. I AM CALLING IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS
JORDAN GRINDS ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN
DISTRICT TWENTY TWO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THREE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THREE SIX FIVE. ONE
THREE HUNDRED PLEASE GO ASK.
ROBERT INCOME. ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVENTEEN NUMBER
SAMPLE JUST AGAIN BE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AYE THREE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
OFFERED TO YOU IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA IF YOU STAY FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. SO
I HAVE TO. FOLLOW YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. ONE ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DEBBIE MORE
SHAUNA CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
ON BEHALF OF WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ITEM ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
OUT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON IS KOBE
BEAN- COLLEEN ON BEHALF OF
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE AND
YOU'LL BE ACTION AND STRONG
SUPPORT SB NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIVE THREE SIX
EIGHT. WHERE WOULD YOU BE
ACTION EAST BAY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME IS
VALUING CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SAN MARCO COURT STRICTLY URGING
AN AYE VOTE ON SB NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
PRESENT IN TINY UP IN PASADENA-
IN STRONG STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS THOMAS IRWIN RESIDENT
AT LEAST LOS ANGELES CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
SEVENTY THREE SCORE AT. HI MY
NAME IS PAUL BIG MORE-
CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND- IN STRONG
SUPPORT PRESS THREE NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT THREE
NINETY FOUR OR HAS. A GOOD
AFTERNOON BOB BAUM TOLD AND
BEAUTIFUL SANTA CRUZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CRUZ. SB NOT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY THREE
EIGHTY NINE TREES GO OUT. HI
THIS IS TINA PATEL CALLING IN
BEHALF OF YOUR LOVE FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CURING THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR I HAD. THAT'S
THREE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS PROBABLY OUT
LEE I'M A RECENT COLLEGE GRADS
FROM BEAUTIFUL EIGHTY FIFTY
THREE IN LOS ANGELES AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M SCOTT
ANNEALING PELADO STRONGLY
SUPPORTING SB NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MORE ATOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA VALLEY
FROM SHERMAN OAKS REPRESENTING
OUR INDIVISIBLE THAT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE. HI THANK
YOU. RIGHT. THREE FORTY NINE.
GIVE ME PAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THERE MY NAME IS THE
OPPOSITE OF ME I AM- SENIOR
COLLEGE STUDENT DEMOCRATIC
SPELL I'M A GOOD AN INCREDIBLE
ONLY ONE SPEECH OR BALL- AND
I'VE BEEN LEFT ON IF THE COURT
AFTER FACT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE FOR SO
TWENTY GO AHEAD. HI NOR WITH
FROM NAPA WITH YOU THE ACT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AROUND ONE FORTY TO
PLAY GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LESLIE THE LEGAL WOMEN VOTE OF
COLOR. AND WE'RE SUPPORT OF S.
B. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RANGERS EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY I'M IN THE
UPPER TO I APOLOGIZE THANK YOU.
FIND ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS GABRIEL
BASSETT IN CINEMA CALIFORNIA
I'M- PRIVATE CITIZEN AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER AND I MADE
SUPPORT ABOUT THE NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
I REPRESENT THE SEALS DOESN'T
COMPANY IN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
YOU ME AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
S. B. THE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE BUYING THREE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
BRITNEY BENNETT THE WITH YOUR A
BUSINESS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN FOUR HUNDRED PLEASE GO ASK.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS I'M
JENNA TAKEN SOMETIME TO CREATE
AN EIGHTY TWENTY NINTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS. THREE THREE TWO- I'M ON
THE OPPOSITION SIDE WHAT DO I
DO. WELL WELL MARK YOU DOWN THE
YEAR IN OPPOSITION BUT WE'RE
LOOKING JUST FOR SUPPORT PLEASE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
I APOLOGIZE I AM WITH THE
OPPOSITION OKAY WE'LL MARKET
DOWN THAT YOU'VE CALLED IN FROM
LOOKING JUST FOR SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. WILL BE ASKING FOR
THE OPPOSITION WITHIN A COUPLE
OF MINUTES. ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS YOU'RE RIGHT. YES SIR
MICHAEL DECORATE FROM CASTRO
VALLEY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RAIN FOREST SAVERNE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ON REGULAR
TV SHOW FROM SAN JOSE SENATE
DISTRICT FIFTEEN REPRESENTING
SOUTH BAY U. M. B. AND I AM IN
THANK YOU. THANK. THREE EIGHTY
FOUR. TRYING TO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M IN A
POSITION. WE'LL MARK THAT YOU
CALLED IN AS OPPOSITIONAL MOVE
ONTO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT BUT-
OPERATOR WE HAVE. FOR SKEWS ME
OPERATOR WE HAVE ABOUT ONE
MINUTE LEFT ON SUPPORT. AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE OVER TO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ABOUT TWO ACTION QUEUE LINES
FOR- SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO I'M MY NAME IS ANNETTE
LIANG AND I'M A COUNCIL MEMBER
BUT I'M IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE OKAY WILL MARK YOU DOWN
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. WE HAVE
A THINK ONE MORE PERSON TO MORE
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
WILL TAKE THOSE TWO. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH PLEASE
PUT ME ON THE LONG QUEUE I'M IN
COMPLETE OPPOSITION MY NAME OF
RITA OKAY THANK YOU RITA. SO
YOU'RE RIGHT ONE FORTY THIRD HE-
HELLO HELLO. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEAH WE CAN YES PLEASE FOR HER
RIGHT I DON'T THINK SHALL I AM-
SINGLE FAMILY HOME OWNER NOT
ANGELES. I AM A SUPPORT ABOUT
TRY TO FIND SOME THANK YOU WELL
MY THANK YOU. WHAT THE WAY TO
IN THE SUPPORT. SO WE ARE TO
START TO WE A UP. I'M GOING TO
REMIND EVERYONE WE'RE GIVING A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MINUTES PER
SIDE SO WE HAD FIFTEEN IN
SUPPORT WHEN I MOVED TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION WE MAY
AND EARLIER BUT- AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY WITH IN
THIS FIFTEEN MINUTE PERIOD
PLEASE SUBMIT WRITTEN WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. OPERATOR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO OPEN THE LINE
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE DO SO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ASPIN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF YOU
NEED TO REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN. OPERATE WE HAVE
ABOUT FIFTY OKAY OPERATOR I'M
GOING TO A LOT TO DO YOU KNOW
YOUNG MAN THAT'S IN THE
AUDITORIUM- PLEASE SPEAK FIRST
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON THE US ARMY DOES ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY'S APOLLO
AALTO LAFAYETTE HUNTINGTON
BEACH LAGUNA BEACH MISSION
VIEJO AGORA HILLS AS WELL AS
THE TRI VALLEY CITIES OF DUBLIN
LIVERMORE PLEASANTON- CENTER
MON IN DANVILLE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- FOR THE
REASONS IDENTIFIED IN THE
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE AND
AUTHOR THINKER MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY OPERATOR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CONTINUE. OKAY WE
HAVE ABOUT SIXTY FIVE IN Q.
WHAT WE'RE TELLING THREE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOCUMENTS ARE LOCKED ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF GLENDALE SAN
MARCOS BURBANK MY COUNTY
COUNCIL MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS OF THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WRITE YOUR TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BALKANS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF
TWENTY SIX DIFFERENT CITIES OF
ALL WITH THE MOP BUT THEY ARE
WITH THE NAY ANALYSIS AND
THEY'RE EITHER OPPOSE PROPOSAL
BUT THE MINUTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I'M THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BACKING FOR MEMBERS
PERSONAL KID OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS AND
SANTA MONICA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE'S BEEN
HANDLED THE MATTER FOR THE
LAFAYETTE AND ALSO A NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA LINES OF LOCAL
ELECTED IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU SH. THANK YOU
RIGHT SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME. IS THAT
ONE MORE TIME. OF THE THIRTY
ALL OF OUR NINE THEN WRONG
OPPOSITE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY SEVENTY NINE SHE'S GLAD.
MAILING STAFF AND ON BEHALF OF
SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS A
MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE NINE- GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND- RESPECTFUL
SENATORS MY NAME IS JOHN
TIGHTLY YOU SEE. REPRESENTING
THE WEST LONG BEACH GOOD
NEIGHBORS IN THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH IN STRONG OPPOSITION. SO
S. B. NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TRICIA
CRANE SHARE OF SANTA MONICA
NORTHEAST NEIGHBORS A CITY
RECOGNIZED NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION TOGETHER WITH OUR
CITY COUNCIL UNANIMOUSLY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS SEAN CALLING
FROM PARK MAKE THE HEIGHTS
COMMUNITY COUNCIL PLANNING AND
LAND USE I AM THE CHAIR- I AM
REPRESENTING MYSELF AS THE
STAKEHOLDER AND TODAY I
STRONGLY ON. BOTH OF THIS
PARTICULAR BELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS THE
SHANNON I'M A BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND WE ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE NOT
HAVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
UNCONSCIONABLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KEVIN
MULDOON WILL PAVE BURBANK
NEIGHBORHOOD PRESERVE OUR LAND
USE DECISIONS AND WE VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE AT B. NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO FIFTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO RIGHT
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE
QUALITY OF WHAT CALIFORNIA BY
FIRST AFFECT NUMBER IN A CAB
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS IN
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT FORTY NINE YES YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD OKAY HI MY NAME IS
JIMMY WITH CORY I LIVE IN THE
FIFTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
I AM A MEMBER OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND I AM A STAKEHOLDER IN THE
PARK MAKE THE HEIGHT THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL AND I'M
CALLING TO. OPPOSE EIGHT SB
NINE AT THE END OF IT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I WON
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH IN THE END THE END OF THE
MONTH. GRAYSON AND WITH LITTLE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SANDY
HUBBARDAND REPRESENTING THE
VALLEY VILLAGE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF THE
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND WE OPPOSE
SB NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
WILL NOT LEYVA CITY ABOUT THE
NO. IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO
SEVEN. ONE ONE OH THREE PLEASE
GO OUT BAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EMILY GABEL LUDDY PAST
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF BURBANK I
REMEMBER APPLICABLE CALIFORNIA
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
KNOW ABOUT TODAY SB NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE ANXIOUSLY
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS HOLLY OSBORNE I AM A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT OF REDONDO
BEACH AND A MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND I APOLOGIZE SB
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JACQUI
ACKLAND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
WEST TOWARDS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WANT FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SANDRA AND
I AM A MEMBER OF EASTSIDE LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY NINE
PEOPLE HAD. JEFF ROBERSON ARGUE
TO THIRTY NINE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
NINE NINE NEGATIVELY IMPACTS TO
HOMEOWNERS. FALL COLORS AND I
REALLY DON'T THANK YOU. RIGHT
TWO NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY TWO NINE SEVEN. WELL MY NAME
IS CALL THE SERVICE I REPRESENT
THE LAFAYETTE HOMEOWNERS
COUNCIL BOARD WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER FIFTY HOMEOWNERS GROUP IN
THE CITY OF LAFAYETTE. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
OUTLINED IN OUR- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH
SANTA MONICA PLEASE OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE EIGHT FOUR. I EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS VIRGINIA CRISIS AND I
AM WITHSTAND THE TAIL
PARTICIPATION AND WE URGE YOU
TO RESPECTFULLY ABOUT NOW SB
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
TO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO FIVE ONE. YES MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH HENRY LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF ST
LAFAYETTE LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND UNITED NEIGHBORS STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CORLISS LEAVE
REPRESENTING THE EAST SIDE
VOIGTS IN LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
AND A MEMBER OF LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOLLY I AM FROM HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT AND I AM OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
CARLY NOT GOOD GALA AND SENATE
BILL UNITED NEIGHBORS AND I
APPROACH SB NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I FOR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS ROBBIE
DAVIS BOARD MEMBER WITH PARK
MESA HEIGHTS IN HOME OWNERS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL DIE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DELETE. IT
THANK YOU RIGHT TO SAY PLEASE
GOING HE AND KENDRA SERVICE
ABOUT RESPONSE PLAY AND LEAST
VOICE LONG BEACH AND UP THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE QUIET. HELLO
GROWTH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
COALITION FOR ECONOMIC SURVIVAL
IN LOS ANGELES AND CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC REGION TWELVE
DIRECTOR IN STRONG OPPOSITION
AND THAT THE MEMBER OF THE L.
A. COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY FORM
YOU THAT THE L. A. B. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE RIGHT THREE THREE PLEASE
GLAD. HI MY NAME IS JASON
KIRSCH I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CATALYST FOR LOCAL CONTROL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YOU'RE RIGHT ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ROBIN MANY CURRENT LAFAYETTE
RESIDENT FORTY SEVEN YEAR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE SIXTY PLEASE CALL
AB. THE BILL SHELTON WITH ME SO
I'M GOING TO THE BEACH STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL I'M A ON SOME
GLOBAL LOAN FROM L. A. COUNTY
NATIVE RESIDENTS OF MINORITY
FONG PEOPLE OF COLOR AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS TRAY JOHN I'M HOUSING
IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE ITSELF. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO SIX TWO OR. THIS
IS RECALL SAN PLUS-
REPRESENTING CULTURAL ACTION
NETWORK AND LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING I'M SURE MEMBERS NAMES
AVAILABLE AUTO AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY THE HALF MOON BAY
STANTON TEMPLE ST PIERRE YOUR
AVAILABLE FOR MONDAY. THANK YOU.
IF YOU. WHICH THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE OR AT. HI
MY IS ABOUT CONNECTING OR MORE
LIKELY LET THERE ARE AROUND IN
MY- BILL. THANK YOU FORTY EIGHT
I THINK HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KRISTEN RASMUSSEN AND I
AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
NEIGHBORHOODS GROUP
REPRESENTING A THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS IN BUT
BALLOT INITIATIVE OFF YET MULTI
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCKET HOMEOWNERS COUNCIL
REPRESENTING OVER FIFTY
HOMEOWNER HOMEOWNERS GROUPS AND
HOAS. AND WE ARE ALL OPPOSED TO
SB. NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT THREE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
SHARON SPRINGER BURBANK CITY
COUNCIL STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
WHITE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY TO SET IT ASIDE
VOICE LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB NINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THREE FORTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. VICKI GOLDBERG
RETURNING THREE ORGANIZATIONS
ABOUT CAPITA MORROW FOR QUALITY
GROWTH AND WATER FLOWS SPREE
STRONG. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY CHIU FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME AT
THE TOP OF THE RESOLUTE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATION.
VIDEO CAN HELP WITH ANY OF ART
AND BETTER WAY FOR CALIFORNIA.
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED ON
BEHALF OF BUILD AFFORDABLE
FACTOR. CORPORATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THANK YOU THANK. YOU
THANK YOU RIGHT THREE ONE GO
OUT. YES REGULAR GOING I'M WITH
A MEMBER OF CAN. AND I'M
OPPOSED THIS THERE'S NO
AFFORDABLE UNITS AND OTHERS.
THANK YOU RIGHT THREE THIRTY TO
PLAY GO AHEAD. OPERATOR WILL
RETRAIN TO UPGRADE WE WOULD
TAKE HIM FOR MORE COLIN FIRTH
AND THAT'S THE END OF TESTIMONY
ON OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ON THE CUANDO I AM A BLUE
COLLAR WORKER HOMEOWNER NUMBER
OF MIRACLE MILE RESIDENTIAL
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS GWENDOLYN
JONES ON THE PRESIDENT OF
CHERRY WITH THE MERIT BLACK
CLAD OLDEST BLACK CLUB IN LOS
ANGELES AND A RESIDENT OF THE
MURDER PARK AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE CALL AT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CALIFORNIA DIFFICULT PAYMENTS
ARE- FOUNDER OF LATINO ALLIANCE
FOR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WITH
MEMBERS IN THE CITIES OF
DOWNEAST ANGELES HUNTINGTON
PARK PARK ABOUT TORRANCE
INCLUDE HERE. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SENATE BILL NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND THIS WILL BE
OUR LAST CALL. THANK YOU RIGHT
TO AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GENTLE THUNDER THE ALBUM OUT
SHASTA AND SISKIYOU COUNTY POSE
SB NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
I WANT TO THANK ALL THOSE THAT
CALLED IN FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL IF YOU
AREN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY WITHIN FIFTEEN
MINUTES THE PERIOD THAT WE HAD.
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR WRITTEN JUST
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PARNELL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. SO WITH
THAT DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THIS WORKING YES SIR
OKAY THANK YOU- FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL- AND FOR YOUR YOU
KNOW CONTINUED WORK ON
INCREASING HOUSING PRODUCTION I
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS TODAY FOR
YOU I'M THE FIRST ONE IS- ONE
THAT I BROUGHT UP LAST YEAR
WHEN YOU PRESENTED S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY I BELIEVE. IN THIS
COMMITTEE- AND IT HAS TO DO-
IT'S REGARDING AN INCREASE IN
DENSITY IN AREAS PRONE TO
WILDFIRES YOU KNOW- MY DISTRICT
IS MAJORITY OF URBAN AREAS-
HOWEVER PARTS OF THE DISTRICT-
ARE ALONG THE FOOTHILLS
ESPECIALLY IN THE COMMUNITIES
OF SUNLAND TUJUNGA- AND THIS
AREA IN MY DISTRICT IS
DESIGNATED AS A FIRE HAZARD
ZONE- LAST YEAR I BELIEVE YOUR
BILL PROVIDED EXEMPTIONS FROM
THOSE FIRES OWNS- HOWEVER THIS
ANALYSIS STATES THAT IT'S
UNCLEAR. WHETHER OR NOT THIS
BILL OR THIS VERSION INTENDS TO
LIMIT STREAMLINING IN THESE
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES SO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO-
SEE IF YOU CAN CLARIFY THAT FOR
ME. THANK YOU SO MUCH I THROUGH
THE CHAIR AS SOON RIVAS IT'S
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK IN PARTNERSHIP ON
SO MANY ISSUES VERY GRATEFUL. I
NUMBER ONE AT THE FIRE
RESTRICTION LANGUAGE THAT'S IN-
SB NINE IS THE SAME AS IN SB
ELEVEN TWENTY LAST YEAR- AND I
ABSOLUTELY HERE AT THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CONCERN OF VIOLENT FAR AND I
NEVER WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
CHAIR BUT- THE CHAIR AND I
REPRESENT. AN AREA OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS BEEN
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRES PROBABLY
MORE THAN ANY OTHER OUT
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE IN THE
NATION. HI MODIFIERS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING- NOW OUT FOR CINEMA
LAKE COUNTIES MENDOCINO COUNTY
AS WELL. ONE OF THE POSITIVE
PARTS OF THIS BILL. IS THERE IS
A BIG FOCUS ON LOCAL CONTROL.
SO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RIGHT NOW
I HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO BE A TO
BE IN DEVELOPMENT IN HIGH FIRE
ZONES. AT THIS BILL IN ITS FORM
NOW DOES NOT BAN DEVELOPMENT
OUT RIGHT ACROSS THE STATE IN
HIGH FIRE ZONES. THAT SAID ANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW
COULD DO THAT FOR ANY TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT RESIDENTIAL OR
COMMERCIAL- NOW. THIS INCLUDES
THE POTENTIAL OF A PROHIBITING
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS SO
CITY OR COUNTY COULD DO THAT.
HI EVEN AS WE SPEAK THERE'S A
COUPLE ISSUES I'D LIKE TO BE A
TOUCH ON ON- BOTH STATUTORY AND
LEGISLATIVE ACTION ON THE
POTENTIAL LIMITATION OF
DEVELOPMENT HIGH FIRE ZONES.
NUMBER ONE- THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY IS CURRENTLY UPDATING
THEIR STANDARDS ABOUT
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD ZONES AND THEY'RE
LOOKING AT POTENTIAL
PROHIBITIONS. FOR RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS TO THOSE HEARINGS
ARE CURRENTLY HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW AT THE BOARD OF FORESTRY.
NUMBER TWO. BUT A COMPLEMENTARY
BILL TO SB NINE IS SENATE BILL
TWELVE SENATE BILL TWELVE WOULD
PROHIBIT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
APPROVING NEW RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES
UNLESS THE DEVELOPMENT CAN MEET
NEW STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS THIS
BILL MADE IT ALL THE WAY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK LAST YEAR- IT'S
BACK WITH SOME AMENDMENTS THIS
YEAR- AND IT WOULD BE FOCUSING
ON NEW WILDFIRE HAZARDS-
ASSESSMENTS AS WELL AS
MITIGATION PLANES THAT I
DEVELOPMENTS WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO BRING FORWARD SANDERS FOR
FIRE SUPPRESSION. OPERATIONS
MANDATORY- ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
TO ENSURE MAINTENANCE OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AS LONG AS THE
DEVELOPMENT IS THERE IN THAT
HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES- BUT
AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
DOES NOT EXPLICITLY BAN AT
DEVELOPMENT BUT ANY CITY OR CAN
YOU CAN DO THAT EVEN IF TO
SPEAK THE LAST PIECE OF SPACES.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL- IS VERY
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPMENT IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD ZONES IN FACT- HE'S
PURSUING THREE DIFFERENT
LITIGATION- CASES ON THREE
DIFFERENT DEVELOPMENTS IN THREE
COUNTIES RIGHT NOW. THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES THE COUNTY OF
LAKE AND I CAN COUNTY SAN DIEGO
ALL FOCUSED ON THE LACK OF.
FIRE SAFETY STANDARDS UNDER
SEQUEL. SO THAT THERE IS AN
INTENSE FOCUS RIGHTFULLY SO AND
THAT IS A PASSION OF MINE AS WE
SEEN HI THOUSANDS OF HOMES
BURNED OVER THE PAST SIX AND A
HALF YEARS. RIGHT AND THAT'S
WHY I THINK SENATE BILL TWELVE
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY- IS WELL
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
ACTION IS GOING TO CHANGE THE
WAY WE DEVELOP LONG TERM. IN
THE CITY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
SO SB TWELVE IS MOVING ALONG
THIS YEAR IN THE PROCESS. YES
MA'AM IT'S- CURRENTLY HERE- IN
THE ASSEMBLY IN PASSIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OUT OF THE
SENATE. OKAY I HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL QUESTION IS ARE YOU-
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT. WE ALL
KNOW THAT WERE IN HOUSING
CRISIS WHICH IS FEEDING INTO
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS- YOU
KNOW I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON. HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND INCREASING THE
SUPPLY IN OUR STATE- HOWEVER WE
ALL KNOW THAT. PURCHASING HOMES
TO TURN THEM AROUND AND YOU
KNOW TO TURN THE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES AND TWO QUAD PLEXUS IS-
AND- IT THEY CAN DISPLACE-
CURRENT RESIDENTS- THAT RESIDE
IN THESE HOMES- THEREFORE
GENTRIFYING. CURRENT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- AND THEN
LIKE I SAID DISPLACING THE
CURRENT RESIDENTS ARE. AND YOU
KNOW. I GUESS THEY'RE FORCED TO
RELOCATE TO AREAS OF WHAT
BETTER FOR EVEN FURTHER AWAY
FROM THEIR WORK- A LOT OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHEN THEY MOVE OUT
THEY GO TO THE ANTELOPE VALLEY-
WHICH IS ABOUT AN HOUR AWAY
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
THEN THEY TRAVEL INTO LOS
ANGELES TO WORK BECAUSE THE
JOBS ARE STILL IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES R. AND SO. I GUESS
I WANT TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHAT YOU OR THE AUTHORS OF THIS
BILL WOULD CONSIDER- YOU KNOW
WOULD YOU CONSIDER LOW INCOME
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVISIONS. IN THE BILL SO THAT
WE CAN KEEP HOUSING COSTS
AFFORDABLE. FOR ALL FAMILIES
THAT LIVE IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT MAY BE DISPLACED. IT'S A
REALLY GOOD QUESTION- IN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
FOCUSED IN ON. IT IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH THE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME DO A DEP DIVE IT'S
ALRIGHT MADAM CHAIR ABSOLUTELY
IN ADDISON NUMBER RIVAS ON THAT
ISSUE. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE AFFORDABLE
AND TALK ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY AND THEN ALSO
TALK ABOUT- GENTRIFICATION AS
WELL THAT'S ALL RIGHT. SO FIRST
AND FOREMOST ON THEIR
AFFORDABLE DISCUSSION WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY- THERE IS A STUDY
DONE ON EIGHTY USE IN THE EAST
BAY IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. IN THE TYPICAL EIGHTY YOU
IN THIS STUDY. IS RENTING AT
ABOUT 62% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. NOW UNDER OUR TENANT
PROTECTION BILL THAT WAS PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR ALONG WITH THE
OVER TWO BILLION WE COVER AT
TENANTS LIVING IN RENTALS UP TO
EIGHTY PERCENT. OF AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. SO THE AVERAGE EIGHTY
YOU IN THE EAST BAY IS RENTING
AT ABOUT 62% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. THE REASON WHY I BRING
THAT UP IS THESE EIGHTY USE
WHICH WOULD BE VERY SIMILAR
SIZE TO THESE DUPLEXES ARE MUCH
MORE AFFORDABLE THAN WHAT WE
WOULD SEE A TYPICAL MARKET
RATE. APARTMENT LET ALONE A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME- NUMBER TWO
THERE'S A REASON WHY HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
THERE'S A REASON WHY BRIDGE
HOUSING ONE OF THE LARGEST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
IN THE STATE SUPPORTS THIS BILL
IN PARTICULAR WE KNOW THAT
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY WHO IS AN
EXPERT ON WORKING ON SMALLER
LOTS AND GETTING THE MOST FOR
FAMILIES I WILL BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THIS BILL TO PROVIDE
PROVIDE A FIRST TIME
HOMEOWNERS. OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE NEVER BE
ABLE TO EXPERIENCE. SO I THINK
THAT'S CRITICAL ON THE TENANT
PROTECTION ISSUES I LIKE TO BE
A CLEAR UP SOME ISSUES ON
TENURE PROTECTION. SO ON TENER
PROTECTIONS TEN PROTECTIONS
APPLY IN SB NINE. SO IT SB NINE
WOULD PROTECT TENANTS. LIVING
IN A SINGLE FAMILY HOME SO I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT- THE
RESTRICTIONS IN REGARD TO
TENANT PROTECTIONS THAT'S
EMBEDDED IN THIS BILL- SB NINE
NUMBER ONE RESPECTS LOCAL
TENANT PROTECTION LAW. SO IF A
CITY OR COUNTY HAS AN EVICTION
LAW OR A MORATORIUM IN PLACE
THAT IS STRICTER THAN WHAT THE
CURRENT. STATUTE IS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT LOCAL
LAW IS GRANDFATHERED IN. THIS
BILL DOES NOT DISRUPT ANY
ACTION THAT IS CITY COUNCIL
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH. NOW IN THIS BILL
THE LANGUAGE STATES IF A TENANT
HAS RESIDED IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS
YOU CAN'T MOVE FORWARD WITH
DEMOLITION. OR TRANSITION OF
THAT SINGLE FAMILY HOME TO A
DUPLEX SO- THAT PROPERTY IS
SIMPLY NOT ELIGIBLE. SO IF A
TENANT HAS LIVED IN THE HOME.
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS YOU
CAN'T TRANSITION AT HOME. THESE
ARE INCREDIBLY STRICT STANDARDS
THAT'S EMBEDDED WITHIN SB NINE
AND REALLY STARTS- A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION IN THE
STATE ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO
STAND STRONG FOR TENANTS IN THE
MILLIONS WHO ARE CALLING THE
SINGLE FAMILY HOME DWELLINGS-
HOME FOR THEIR FAMILIES. NOW
THIS BILL ALSO HAS CHANGED
SINCE THE LAST TIME I WAS IN
FRONT OF YOU. WE'VE HEARD A LOT
OF FEEDBACK THAT- TO AVOID
SPECULATION. AVOID LARGE-
PROFITEERING GROUPS COMING IN
TO BETTER DEVELOP THESE LOTS
THAT OWNERS SHOULD HAVE TO LIVE
THERE. AND SO NOW IN SB NINE-
IF A CITY COUNCIL OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WANTS TO PUT AN
OWNER OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS ON
TO A FOUR PLEX OR DUPLEX. THEY
CAN DO THAT. UNDER ELEVEN
TWENTY LAST YEAR THEY COULD
NOT. IN THAT'S RESPONDING TO
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- IN
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS SO THAT IF
I OWN AND I LIVE IN A COMMUNITY
WHERE MY NEIGHBORHOOD IS BUILT
IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. AT THEIR
CORE ADD VERY SMALL HOME OF
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SQUARE
FEET LARGER LOTS OF QUARTER
ACRE MOST OF THE HOMES IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD EITHER HAVE AN
EIGHTY YOU OR A G. EIGHTY YOU
AND INDEED YOU ALREADY ON IT-
AND I THINK THAT'S THE OTHER
PIECE I'D LIKE TO DESCRIBE.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF- TALK
ABOUT HOW. HOMEOWNERS COULD
DOUBLE DIP. IF YOU HAVE AN
EIGHTY YOU A GT ON A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME YOU CAN'T IT'S A
MAXIMUM OF FOUR UNITS ON A LOT.
THAT'S IT- NO I THINK I'D LIKE
TO SAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER INTO THE
CHAIR IF IT'S ALL RIGHT. IS THE
ISSUE ISSUE OF GENTRIFICATION.
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE. TO BE ABLE TO
AVOID GENTRIFICATION. BUT THIS
BILL IS ALSO ABOUT
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH. AND I
DON'T THINK WE CAN ASSUME. THAT
IT'S ALL GOING TO BE PROFITEERS
IT'S GONNA BE COMING INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WILL BE
SELLING OFF AND IN HOMEOWNER
SELLING OFF THEIR HOMES I WILL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE HOMES THAT HAVE A GED
YOU AN EIGHTY OR BOTH HAVE THE
HOMEOWNER LIVING IN THE FRONT
HOUSE. I AND WE SEE THAT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO IS WELL. AND THAT
BUILDS LONG TERM
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH FOR
THOSE FAMILIES. AS YOU'RE ABLE
TO BUILD THAT LAND VALUE UP
WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL UNITS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE MORE
AFFORDABLE THAN WHAT THE ACTUAL
MARKET RATE WOULD BE. SO SOME
MEMBER I'D BE HAPPY TO GO
FURTHER- IF THEY'RE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ON THIS AND BUT I
THINK I SOME THE RESISTANCE OF
SOME REALLY GOOD POINTS AND-
THAT'S WHY WE'VE REALLY TAKEN
THIS ISSUE OF TENANT
PROTECTION. IN AFFORDABILITY
SO- SO STRONGLY. THANK YOU AND
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE- YOUR
EFFORTS I KNOW I'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU AND
OTHERS- YOU KNOW THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT TO VOTE FOR ME TO
TAKE YEAH- BECAUSE OF
OPPOSITION AND MY DISTRICT IN
MY REGION- YOU KNOW I KNOW
YOU'RE- YOU'RE WILLING. TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THERE ARE. A
PROTECTIONS FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS- FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- YOU KNOW LIKE TODAY I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
BASED ON- OUR EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS AND COMMITMENTS
THAT YOU'VE MADE- YOU KNOW IT
JUST TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION YOU KNOW I. I DO
BELIEVE WE NEED- HOUSING MORE
HOUSING AND ARE STATE TEN. I'M
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS- BUT- YOU
KNOW I DO WANT US TO MAKE SURE
THAT. YOU CONTINUE TO SPEAK TO
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN. BOB AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THAT. WERE ABLE TO
COME. TOGETHER WITH SOME TYPE
OF AGREEMENT THAT. ASSURES US
THAT THIS WILL BE AND THE SPELL
THAT- IT THIS IS NOT JUST-
SOMETHING THAT. WILL BENEFIT
DEVELOPERS ONLY. SEVEN I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU AND YOU
HAVE BEEN A VERY LOUD AND CLEAR
ABOUT WHERE YOU WANT TO GO I
WILL BE HONEST- IN TWO NATIONS-
IN THE ARGUMENT AND WE'VE HEARD
YOU LOUD AND CLEAR WHICH IS
WHY. WE'VE MADE AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL FROM LAST YEAR- BASED
OFF OF FEEDBACK YOU OTHER
MEMBERS AS WELL AS NEIGHBORHOOD
GROUPS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE HAD. YOU OF MY COMMITMENT-
I WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CHAIRWOMAN WE NEED ALL THE TIME
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS AND YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT. THAT AT
WILL CONTINUE THAT AND IF THERE
ARE ANY GROUPS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE YOU TO MEET WITH IN YOUR
DISTRICT WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO
SO AS WELL IN IS WHEN I SAY
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR WORK AND AT
FOR YOUR CONSTANT DAILY TO BE
ABLE TO MEET AND- TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN
CRITICAL TO THE SHAPE OF. THIS
BILL AND I KNOW. THAT WE MORE
WORK TO GO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SOME MA'AM. YES WE- A QUESTION
FROM A SETTLEMENT. MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR A SIMILAR-
THAT TURNED ON- SO I'M LOOKING
AT AN OPPOSITION LETTER RIGHT
NOW FROM ONE OF MY CITIES AND I
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
FOR DRESSING THE ISSUE OF HIGH
FIRE ZONES A VISTA BORDERS ON
THE HIGH FIRE. ANA AREA AND
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THE INCREASING DENSITY THAT
COULD BE HAPPENING WITH THIS-
ONE QUESTION I WANT TO ASK IS A
CITY OPTED IN FOR THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT I'VE HEARD
FROM CONSTITUENTS IS THAT- THE
ONLY PEOPLE THAT HAVE ACCESS TO
THE CAPITAL ACTUALLY
TRANSFORMING USE SB NINE WOULD
BE THOSE WHO ALREADY ARE VERY
AFFLUENT SO THE MIDDLE INCOME
AREAS WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO CAPITAL WOULD BE VERY
HARD FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THIS. IN A WAY THAT
IS EQUITABLE DO YOU HAVE A
COMMENT TO THE TO THAT ARE IN
RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION I
THINK- I'LL TALK ABOUT EIGHTY
USING DUPLEXES IN GENERAL IF
IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU I THINK
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO FOCUS
ON FINANCING OF EIGHTIES JD
USE. THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT-
VERY FOCUSED ON- AND I THINK
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO ADVANCE
A FINANCING MECHANISM TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR MIDDLE INCOME
HOMEOWNERS LOWER INCOME
HOMEOWNERS TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE BUT WHAT I'LL SAY IS
THIS- RIGHT. NOW IN MANY OF
THESE CITIES THEY WOULD ALLOW A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME TO BE ABLE
TO BE DEVELOPED. I BEHIND AT
HOME THERE HAS NOT BEEN NEARLY
AS MUCH- VOICE TO THAT ISSUE
VERSUS BEING ABLE TO PUT A
DUPLEX BEHIND HOME. IN WHAT WE
KNOW IS BASED OFF OF THE STUDY
THAT WE SAW IN THE EAST BAY- IS
THAT THESE EIGHTY USE AND I'LL
SAY DUPLEXES ARE GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE. MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE THAN A RENTING OF A
SECOND SINGLE FAMILY HOUSE ON A
LOT. I BECAUSE OF THE SMALLER
SQUARE FOOTAGE RIGHT- IN THE
LACK OF THE YARD SO I DO THINK
BY DESIGN THEY ARE GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE. AND THAT
THE ONE OTHER PIECE OF SAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I DON'T
MEAN TO MINIMIZE THE TIME YOU
KNOW I STOP IN THIRTY SECONDS I
HAVE THREE MORE QUESTIONS OKAY-
IS THAT- IT'S ALL EYES WILL BE
CLEAR TO IS THAT- FLOOR AREA
RATIO. AT SET BACK AS WELL AS
HIGH ARE NOT AT THIS BILL DOES
NOT OVERRIDE ANY OF THOSE THREE
ISSUES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
ALSO CONTINUE TO APPLY SET
BACKS FLORI RATIO AND HIGH. I
TO THESE UNITS. I'M SORRY THAT
ONE OF SOME NO THAT'S OKAY
BECAUSE THAT LEADS INTO MY NEXT
QUESTION SO WHEN WE DID THE
INCREASE IN DENSITY AND ANTHONY
THIS WE PUT A MAXIMUM AVERAGE
SIZE. ON THE UNITS AS THEIR
MAXIMUM AVERAGE SIZE THOUGH
WHAT HAPPENS IN MY AREAS THEY
WOULD BUILD LARGER TWO THOUSAND
THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
MCMANSIONS WHICH WE KNOW BY
THAT SIZE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE AFFORDABLE AND ANYWAY IT'S
NOT LIKE YOU TAKE A TWO MILLION
DOLLAR HOME. DIVIDED FOR EACH
COST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND YOU
TAKE A TWO MILLION DOLLAR HOMES
BUT IN THE FOR EACH ONE COSTS
ONE POINT TWO ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION RIGHT SO IS THERE A
MAXIM AVERAGE SIZE THAT THAT
SIZE ITSELF IN. LEAD TO MORE
NATURAL AFFORDABILITY. THERE IS
NO MAXIMUM SIZE BUT WHAT I'LL
SAY IS THAT YOU COULD DEVELOP
ON A TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
BUILDING- THE MINIMUM IS
DEVELOPING A TWELVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT BUILDING PARCEL- SO
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO GET YOU
TO IT SIX HUNDRED SQUARE FEET-
BUT- THERE THERE IS NOT A
MAXIMUM I SIZE ON THIS AT THIS
TIME MMHM. AND THEN MY NEXT
QUESTION GOES TO RENO- AND MOST
OF MY CITIES OUR ISSUE IS NOT
MODERATE OR ABOVE MODERATE
HOUSING IT IS ACTUALLY THE LOW
AND VERY LOW INCOME HOUSING AND
IF YOU TAKE A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME AND YOU DIVIDE IT WHAT'S
THE RENO CREDIT THAT CITIES
WOULD GET THROUGH SB NINE. FOR
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING. YEAH I
MEAN I THINK RIGHT NOW THAT
THESE WOULD BE CONSIDERED.
MARKET RATE RENTALS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THOUGH WE KNOW THAT
BASED OFF THE STUDY IN THE EAST
BAY THAT THE EASY TO USE SO
EIGHTY USER PROBABLY ANYWHERE
BETWEEN- FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN SEVEN HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET THEY'RE RENTING IT SIXTY
TWO PERCENT. OF THE MEDIAN SO
THAT THEY ARE MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE BUT I THINK THE
OTHER PIECES- JUST WANT TO
MENTION IS THAT SB NINE IS PART
OF A LARGER PACKAGE THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON. BUT THERE IS NOT
GONNA BE A SILVER BULLET TO BE
ABLE TO SOLVE THIS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS. AND THAT'S WHY
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
LOOKING AT AN EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN HOMELESS
HOUSING THAT'S WHY WE'RE
WORKING THE SENATE WILL BE
ADVANCING IN THIS PACKAGE LED
BY TONI ATKINS. ON THE SIX
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BOND WHICH
WE SO DESPERATELY NEED THERE'S
GONNA BE NEARLY TWO BILLION IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. FOR
ADDITIONAL FOR DOUBLE HOUSING
AND THAT EIGHTY YOU FINANCING
THAT I MENTIONED. THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF YOUR BUDGET SUB
AND IN FACT CENTER CABALLERO IS
HERE AND IS WELL THERE IS RIGHT
NOW- THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE A DO
YOU FINANCING IN THE BUDGET
APPROVED OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA
NEED THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT
ON THAT. WHICH WOULD USHER IN
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE UNITS-
BUT- NOW CITIES COULD DO SOME
TYPE OF DEED RESTRICTION RIGHT
THAT. WOULD THEN MAKE IT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO CITIES
COULD BE. THE EXTRA HOMES
DEVELOPED UNDER SB NINE TO BE.
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE AND
80% AB AMYRA BELOW. THE BUT
THEY POTENTIALLY COULD. YES
MMHM- AND THE LAST QUESTION AND
YOU YOU KIND OF TOUCHED ON IT
SO. YOU SAID THAT THERE IS A
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF FOUR UNITS
THAT COULD BE CONVEYED
SEPARATELY AFTER A YEAR. RIGHT
WHAT.WHAT COVERAGES ARE
INCLUDED IN SB NINE. THAT WOULD
PRECLUDE. THEM FROM ACTUALLY
BUILDING A JDO IN EIGHTY
BECAUSE AFTER THAT POINT
THEY'RE STILL SINGLE FAMILY
HOME. SO THEY CAN STILL HAVE
THAT START ON THE MECHANISM AS
BENIGN THAT THAT HOW YOU LIMIT
THAT WHEN ONCE YOU'RE YOU'RE
OUT AND THEN THEY'RE BEING
CONVEYED SEPARATELY. YES MA'AM-
SO. TWO THINGS ONE. THAT THE
HOMEOWNER IS GOING TO WHEN THEY
PULL THEIR PERMIT WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION WHETHER IT'S A
CITY OR COUNTY THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SAY WITHIN
THEIR PERMIT. ON WHAT THEY'RE
GONNA PLACE ON A LOT WHETHER
IT'S A SINGLE FAMILY HOME HGTV
EIGHTY OR DUPLEX NUMBER TWO
THERE'S ADDITIONAL RESTRICTIONS
BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DISCLOSE HOW MANY WATER AND
SEWER HOOK UPS. AND ELECTRICAL
HOOKUPS THAT THEY HAVE ON THOSE
UNITS AND SO I'M NOT AT ALL
TRYING TO PASS THE BUCK BUT
THIS AGAIN IS PART OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL THAT LOCAL CITY OR
COUNTY THAT WOULD BE APPROVING
THIS DEVELOPMENT. WILL KNOW
WHAT TYPE OF DEVELOPMENT- WOULD
BE PUT ON THERE WHETHER IT'S A
G. D. U. EIGHTY OR DUPLEX-
BASED OFF OF ONE THEIR ACTUAL
BURNING BUILDING PERMIT FOR THE
UNITS. AND THROUGH THE HOOK UPS
THAT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
APPLY FOR THROUGH THE LOCAL
WATER DISTRICT WITH THE CITY OR
THE COUNTY. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS YES JUST-
WAS HOPING- MR CENTER OF YOU
CAN PROVIDE SOME CLARIFICATION-
MY OFFICE IS RECEIVING NUMBER
OF CALLS AND ENQUIRIES ABOUT
HOW. SB I COULD POTENTIALLY
IMPACT FRANCE'S THERE H. AWAY-
HOMEOWNERS AS CATFISH AND SO
IF- YOU COULD. SPEAK TO THAT
AGREEMENT HOAS ARE EXCLUDED
FROM THIS BILL SO WOULD NOT
IMPACT A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALSO WOULD NOT
IMPACT ON HISTORIC DISTRICTS
ARE LANDMARK DISTRICTS EITHER
GREAT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS- I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. HER MOTION
NINE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST SECONDS
IT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WITH RESPECT LASSEN I DON'T I
JUST WANNA SAY MINIATURE AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
THE WONDERFUL QUESTIONS ARE
ADVANCED SEDATE THE COMMENTS
AND TO ALL THE FEEDBACK AND I
PROMISE YOU MADAM CHAIR AND TO
THE COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH THOSE WHO
SUPPORT AND MOST INTENSELY MEET
WITH THOSE WHO OPPOSE AND HOW
WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
DISPELLING RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU IN
CENTER I REALLY APPRECIATE DO
THINK ALL THE CLARIFICATION
THAT- PEOPLE MAY HAVE NOT READ
AMENDMENTS AND CHANGES TO THE
BILL- I ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT HE WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON A BILL AND TO SENATOR
ATKINS- AND I KNOW YOU WORKED
REALLY HARD TO- AMOUNT OF TIME
TO STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN
PRESERVING LOCAL CONTROL YEAH
WELL ALLOWING MORE HOME
CONSTRUCTION. AND THERE'S NO
EASY SOLUTION TO THIS AND SO-
WE'RE TRYING TO RESOLVE A
HOUSING CRISIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON AND ON AND IT'S GONNA TAKE
TIME AND IT WAS A BENEFICIAL
THE YOU MENTIONED OTHER BILLS
THAT MAY BE COMING OUR WAY OR
NOT- THAT ARE ALL LINKED
TOGETHER FOR I HAVE GOOD MAKE
GOOD POTENTIAL HOUSING POLICY
SO. I THINK THAT THE BILL DOES
WHAT WE WANTED TO AT THIS POINT
I THINK THERE IS SOME MORE WORK
TO BE DONE ON IT AND SO WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
LACKEY. LACKEY NOW BLOOM.
BERMAN THAT VOTE.
BOERNER HORVATH NOT.
BOERNER HORVATH VOTE ROB. FIFTY
FIVE MODEL ALL RIGHT
THREE OF US LIST WE I ROBERT.
ROBERT RIVAS HAVE A PELL. HI
THAT'S FIVE ONE OKAY THE BILL
IS OUT AND THEN WE HAVE ALL OUR
MEMBERS HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND MAY CONTAIN FOR
PRESENTING THAT TODAY WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
THREE TWO THREE SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU FOR GIVING
HER A LESSON EARLY AND WE DO
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION OF DO
PASS TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB THREE TWO
THREE WHICH WOULD CREATE A ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAY STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS FOR CLAIMS
AGAINST WATER AND SEWER AGENCY
RATE SETTINGS. WATER AND SEWER
THE SEWER UTILITY BUDGETS ARE
FUNDED BY REVENUE COLLECTED
THROUGH SERVICE RATES THESE
RATES PROVIDE THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO SUPPLY SAFE
DRINKING WATER UPGRADE AND
IMPROVE AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OPERATE EFFECTIVELY.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS LAWSUITS
THAT SEEK REFUNDS OR SEEK TO
INVALIDATE EXISTING RATE
STRUCTURES YEARS AFTER RATES
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED AND
COLLECTED. THESE DELAYED LOTS
WHOSE CAN THREATEN IN A BIT AND
AGENCIES ABILITY TO REPAY DEBT
GUARANTEED BY REV REVENUE FROM
RATES DERAIL ONGOING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
GENERALLY UNDERMINE AND
AGENCIES ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
STABLE BUDGETS. NECESSARY TO
OPERATE EFFECTIVELY. LATELY
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
LEGAL CHALLENGES FILED AGAINST
WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES RATE
STRUCTURES. FOR SOME OF THE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN SUED
THE CHALLENGED RATES WERE
ADOPTED YEARS AFTER THE
LAWSUIT. AND NOW WITH THE
ADDITIONAL STRAIN OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
PROHIBITS PROHIBITING WATER
SHUT OFFS REGARDLESS OF A
CUSTOMER'S ABILITY TO PAY WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES ARE UNDER
CONSTANT FINANCIAL STRAIN AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
ARE AT RISK. THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER THE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOR MUNICIPAL
ELECTRICAL RATES OR CHARGES SB
TWO THIRTY TWO ADDS CONSISTENCY
TO EXISTING LAW. FOR ALL THREE
THE AUTHORIZING A LOCAL AGENCY
OR INTERESTED PERSON TO BRING A
VALIDATION ACTION IN SUPERIOR
COURT DETERMINED THE BILL THE
LADY OF A FEED. BOB FREE OR
CHARGE FOR SEWER AND SEWER
WATER AND SEWER SERVICES IF A
VALIDATION ACTION IS NOT
BROUGHT WITHIN THOSE HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS PARTIES WOULD BE
BARRED FROM CHALLENGING. THE
VALIDITY OF A FEE OR CHARGE. BY
ALLOWING CUSTOMERS TO BRING
CHALLENGES WITHIN A REASONABLE
BUT LIMITED PERIOD OF TIME THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BALANCE INTO
INTEREST OF REPAIRS WITH THOSE
OF THE PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER
AGENCY IN AND THE CURRENT
PRACTICE. THANKS THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE TO TESTIFIED SUPPORT IS
CHRIS ANDERSON FROM AWKWARD
DISSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES AND PAUL COOK
THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
MOVES ABOUT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FOR MOTION SECOND- YOU RE
HAVE- MIST- CHRISTOPHER
ANDERSON ON THE PHONE PLEASE OR
PAUL COOK PLEASE. OPERATOR AND
WHILE WE DO THAT I DO NOT. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE FROM IN THE
AUDIENCE FOR THE BILL. FOR IN
SUPPORT OF IT. OKAY WHY DON'T
WE HAVE YOU TESTIFIED. WORK
LIKE JUST THE- I- SKEWS ME YOU
KNOW WHAT LET ME HEAR THE TWO
ABOVE AYE AYE FUNK AYE THOSE.
SECURING GOT LOST HERE THANK
YOU WILL HAVE A MR ANDERSON AND
MR COOK TO SPEAK FIRST. GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON THE
HALFPENNIES DESTINATION THE
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES OF
PROUD SPONSOR OF SB THREE TWO
THREE- PURCHASED ONE I THINK
THAT MANY STAFF FOR THEIR
KNOWLEDGE THIS. TAKE THE TIME
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS BILL ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR CABALLERO AND HER STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
BILL. SB THREE TWO THREE PASSED
THE SENATE LAST NIGHT WITH
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT CAME
IN PART BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES
NOT PRESENT A NEW OR
REVOLUTIONARY IDEA THIS BILL
ALIGNS LONG. PRECEDENT EXISTING
LOFT HUNDRED TWENTY DAY STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS ARE IF HE'S
ALREADY PROVIDER PUT MEANS FALL
LECTURE CREATES CONNECTION. AT
THE CHARGES I WATERED STILL
RAGING THESE. AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EATEN CHARGES. THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE STATUE
LIMITATIONS FOR IMPORTANT
POLICY READS AND WANTED TO
RECCHI CAN'T RECOGNIZE THE NEED
TO REDUCE FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY
FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES. SB THREE TWO THREE
SPEAK TO PROVIDE SIMILAR
PROTECTIONS TO WATER AND SEWER
SERVICE AND SIMPLY CLOSE THIS
GAP IN EXISTING LAW- PUBLIC
WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES ARE
LARGELY FUNDED BY RATE REVENUE
THESE RATES PROVIDE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILT WEAPONS
SYSTEMS MAKING RELIABLE
OPERATION. OR THE LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO WATER AND SEWER
AGENCY RATE STRUCTURES NAPA
FINANCIALLY DESTABILIZING
EFFECT FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES. AS
A CLEANING OUT THIS POINTS OUT
PROP TO EIGHTEENTH AND FERTILE
GROUND FOR LITIGATION THE
REQUESTED- CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT
AGAINST EIGHTY ONE WATER
SUPPLIERS CALIFORNIA IS JUST
THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF THE
BOUNDS OF PROP TWO EIGHTEEN-
DETESTED. IN THAT CASE MANY OF
THE DEPEND AGENCIES ADOPTED
THEIR RATE YEARS BEFORE THE
LAWSUIT WAS FILED. AND LONG
AFTER REVENUE WAS COLLECTED AND
EXPAND IT SB THREE Q. THREE
DRESSES THIS ISSUE BY ALLOWING
REPAIRS TO BRING LAWSUITS
WITHIN A LIMITED FOR A
REASONABLE PERIOD OF TIME
IMPORTANTLY. THIS BILL
MAINTAINS CRITICAL EIGHT CARE
PROTECT ARE IN FOR IN THE- ALL
MOST NOTABLY PROP TO EIGHTEEN
REQUIRES WATER INTO AGENTS.
FIVE SIX NOW AND MEET REQUIRE.
PRIOR TO ADOPTING NEW RATES.
WERE MANY OTHER LOCAL GUY THE
AND ARE HAPPENED. OF A HUNDRED
EIGHT ON THE- NOW ARE SAID TO
PROP EIGHT. SIMPLY PUT SB TWO
THREE STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
REPAIRS AND NINE PUBLIC WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES TO AVOID
UNNECESSARY FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY. PLEASE REGION'S
WOODCREST DRIVE OUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR COOK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS SB
THREE TWO THREE REJECTED AS-
UNPOPULAR GENERAL MANAGER OF
THE YEAR RANGE WATER DISTRICT
AND WE'RE A PUBLIC RETAIL.
WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES
SERVING CENTRAL ORANGE COUNTY.
AND IS THIS YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF SB THREE TWO THREE LIKE TO
DESCRIBE THE VERY PUBLIC AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS OF
REPORTING THAT WE UTILIZED-
RANCH WATER DISTRICT. PROPERTY
WE CAN REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ARE
EXPENSIVE. BUT THEY'RE ONLY
PART OF THE PUBLIC PROCESS THAT
WE CAN TALK. MICHAEL WATER AND
WASTE WATER AGENCIES ARE TO BE
BEGIN ITS RATE SETTING PROCESS
WITH A COST OF SERVICE STUDY.
THIS DETAILED STUDY EXPLAINS
THE METHODOLOGY FOR HOW RACERS
THAT AND HOW COSTS ARE
ALLOCATED AMONG OUR CUSTOMERS.
BECAUSE OF PROP TWO EIGHTEEN
STRICT COST OF SERVICE
PRINCIPLES RESETTING IS TIED
DIRECTLY TO AN AGENCY BUDGET.
AND THAT IS WHERE WE PROVIDE
THE BASIS FOR THE PROPOSED
RIGHT. OUR DIVERSITY EXPLAINS
IT RAISES. POLICY DECISIONS ARE
EXPENSES PROPOSED RATE IMPACT
AT MULTIPLE PUBLIC MEETINGS.
FOR CURRENT REASONING PROCESSES
BUT AT LEAST NINE MEETINGS-
HEALTHCARE. PART TO RAISE BEING
CONSIDERED FOR ADOPTION WE ALSO
MAIL THE PROPERTY OWNER AND
CUSTOMER YOU PROP TO EIGHTEEN
NOTICE. AT LEAST FORTY FIVE
DAYS PRIOR TO A PUBLIC HEARING
ON THE PROPOSED RACES REYES
NOTICED PROVIDED DETAILS. ON
THE PROPOSED RAISE ALONG WITH
RECENT FOR JOCULARLY THE NORTH
ALSO INCLUDES INFORMATION ON
HOW TO REPAIR COMMENTS OR
PROTESTS THREE. AND ARE TO BE
THE RESPONSE PERSONALLY TO EACH
PROTEST LETTER OR HARM
EVERYTHING. ONLY AFTER THE VERY
PUBLIC AND VERY EXPENSIVE
PROCESS OF A RACE CONSIDERED
FOR ADOPTION OUR BOARD. BECAUSE
THE FREE TRANSFER PROCESS WE
BELIEVE THAT A. HUNDRED TWENTY
STATUTES LIMITATIONS. A PROGRAM
BETWEEN RICK IMPROV REACH OUT.
ALLOWING FIRST HARPER RATE TO
REYES. WHO CLOSE LIKE AFFECTED
EUROPE. SB THREE TWO THREE
HOURS ACTUALLY REQUEST YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY-
AVAILABLE PRETTY QUICK. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS COOK
YOU HAVE ANY UP. WITNESS IN UP.
THE CRISPY TODAY. I DON'T
ANYTHING ON RAY SO DO WE GO
INTO WOODEN IN. OF NAY YEAR YOU
BUSY- ORGANISER BECAUSE- AND WE
ARE ONE HERE IN THE- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT I SAW DOES ON
BEHALF OF THE EAST ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
ARE THERE ANY- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THREE TWO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
TEN IN Q. OR BOARD TRYING TO
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING VALLEY
WATER OTHERWISE AND IT CAN
ACQUIRE VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IF THE COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RANGE FOR FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILL BE AT
THE LEAD SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FOR SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND SANTA MARGARITA
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN FOR SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS TALK MEANWHILE ON
BEHALF OF HOW MUTUAL AID
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CARE ABOUT
THE BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RANGE FOR
SIXTY FIVE TREES COLLAPSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBER BETH- ALSO ON BEHALF OF
INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
AND CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY PAMELA
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT FOR
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO- TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FALCONS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF TORRANCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALMOST
RUSHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT AROUND SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE CALL HAVE. ONE
ERICA DOLLAR UNDER AFTER YOUR
LINDA WATER DISTRICT GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS ON THE NEW
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR WHAT DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. AT THREE
TWO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THREE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KERN MEMBERS ONE OF THE
TOP THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS OF AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE TWO
MORE COMMENTS THANK YOU IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT TO THE NEXT
BY NUMBER. WHITE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT THESE CALL ASK. THE
SCOTSMAN HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT BY NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS SAM JORAM
AND I DON'T REPRESENTED WATER
AGENCIES THAT I FEEL THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BEA LOT MORE
TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE OFTENTIMES
THESE THEY DON'T YOU LIKE REACH
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. FOR SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE ABOUT THE
ON AIR QUALITY I WAS SO TO
DURING THAT THE PORTABLE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED FOR MESA
WATER DISTRICT AND TO ALL THE
UTILITIES DISTRICT AND THE PORT
OF THE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
CRAZY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR NO
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
I JUST HAVE A- A COMMENT- AND
HOPING THAT IT LEADS TO A
FURTHER DISCUSSION. AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. THERE'S BEEN
SOME- CONCERNS OF MY DISTRICT.
AS FAR AS THE- LACK OF NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS AND THE TIMING
THAT IS PUT ON THERE FOR THE
PROPERTY OWNERS. I JUST WANTED
TO- RAISE THAT CONCERN HERE
THIS COMMITTEE. TO ENCOURAGE
ONGOING DIALOGUE TO ENSURE THAT
IF THERE IS AMENDMENTS THAT
COULD BE TAKEN PRIOR TO-
GETTING TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
WE WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
THAT DISCUSSION. TO CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT DOT THROUGH THE CHAIR.
CREATED HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE REALTORS ABOUT EXACTLY
THAT SAME ISSUE- AND- MORE ON
THAT LATER. BUT WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF HAVING DISCUSSIONS
WE OBVIOUSLY WANT FULL FULL
NOTIFICATION. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SAYING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION- I
BELIEVE IT'S FROM EXCUSE ME-
BOERNER HORVATH OF AND THE
SECOND TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS- WHICH I CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS OKAY WELL I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORD AND IT'S SO IMPORTANT ONE
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE WE NEED TO
HAVE- WATER PROVIDERS HAVE THE
SAME- ISSUES FINANCIAL
STRUGGLES TO STRUGGLES DURING
THE PANDEMIC IN CREATING
CONSISTENCY AND CERTAINTY.
DURING THESE TIMES IS REALLY-IMPORTANT SO I REALLY LIKE THE
BILL AND I'M SUPPORTING IT
TODAY. AND THE MOTIONS DO
PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
IRAQI. BLOOM I'VE- AYE FOR
HARDWARE HI THERE ARE BETTER I
ALMOST. ALMOST GOD LIVES RIVAS
HI THIS RIVERSIDE ROBERT RIVAS
HI ROBERT RIVAS AD VOEPEL HI
THE BILL HI YOU HAVE SEVEN
ZERO. OKAY WE'LL HOLD THE
RIPPLE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITION
ELLE LONGER MATCH THANK YOU
SENATOR APPRECIATE IT NEXT IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB. SEVEN
EIGHTY A SENATOR CORTESE. AND
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THIS IS YOUR FIRST A
SHOWING IN OUR- COMMITTEE SO
WELCOME. YES SIR THANK YOU
MEASURE FOR NOTING THAT TEN- AS
YOU KNOW MY WIFE MENTIONED THAT
THE- THEN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY- ON THE FOR THE
ASSEMBLY THAT MY FATHER MY
FATHER CHAIRED THIS COMMITTEE
IS EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS OLD NOW-
HE LEFT THE LEGISLATURE IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX DURING A
WAVE OF TERM LIMITS SO. IS A
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO
MENTION THAT YOU KNOW THAT SIZE
BEGIN TO BE ALLOWED INTO THESE
ROOMS YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT DURING COLD AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE- THERE'S A-
SPECIAL FEELING FOR ME AND IT
IS. IT'S AN HONOR YOU KNOW TO
BE BEFORE YOU TODAY REALLY A
SIGN OF YOUR FATHER ARE BEST
WILL DO I WILL HE HE WILL BE
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT. I WOULD BE
SURPRISED HE WATCHES. IN A
COUPLE OF TIMES ACTUALLY-
THAT'S SAID- AGAIN GOOD
AFTERNOON AND- I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN EIGHTY IT'S A
BILL THAT IMPLEMENTS CHANGES TO
BOTH ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCE DISTRICTS OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS III FT'S- AND
COMMITTEE REVITALIZATION
INVESTMENT THE FORTY C. R. I.
A.'S. AND THOSE LAWS TO HELP
CITIES USE THESE TOOLS TO
FINANCE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. SINCE THE ELIMINATION
OF REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN
TWENTY ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED SEVERAL TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS. HE I HAVE
THESE IN C. R. I. A.'S HAVE
EMERGED AS TOOLS THAT ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES TO USE A TAX
INCREASE INCREMENTS THE
PARTICIPATING ENTITIES TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS. HOWEVER THE
MINIMAL UPTAKE THE BOTH THE
FT'S IN C. R. I. IS HAS PROVED
THAT THEY ARE OVERLY CUMBERSOME
TO ESTABLISH AND OPERATE. WITH
A HOUSING CRISIS RAVAGING
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE. THE REVITALIZATION OF
THESE TOOLS IS WELL OVERDUE. SB
SEVEN EIGHTY MAKE SEVERAL
CHANGES. TO BOTH THE I. F. D.
N. C. R. I. A LAW. THAT WILL
ENABLE LOCAL AGENCIES TO USE
THESE TOOLS TO EFFECTIVELY
STIMULATE DEVELOPMENT. IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AMONG OTHER
MINOR CHANGES THE BILL
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS FOR
AMENDING EXISTING PLANS AND
REWRITES THE TENURE PROTEST
PROCESS IN C. R. I. EQUALITY.
TO MAKE C. R. I. A.'S IN III OF
DIS MORE VIABLE FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES. TO CREATE CAN'T
OPERATE. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND CONSULTANTS OF. THIS
COMMITTEE IN PREVIOUS
COMMITTEES FOR. WORKING WITH US
EXTENSIVELY ON THIS BILL- THERE
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN A LOT OF
GIVE AND TAKE UP TO THIS POINT
AND I FEEL IT'S RIGHT AS WE
COME IN HERE TODAY HERE TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT IS ERROR IN
THE WORLD FROM THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO AND MICHAEL LANE.
FROM SPUR. IN ADDITION- DAN
CHARACTER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. WILL BE ON THE
LINE. TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS
IF THERE ARE ANY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN- IN THE-
CONCLUDE THEIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE SENATOR WE'LL OPEN THE
LINES FOR MICHAEL LANE. YOUR
END AARON LAUREL MOVE THE BELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE NUMBERS.
PROCEED. IT'S NOT PART OF THEIR
MEMBERS MIGHT BE MEMBERS AGAIN
WHO THEIR LARA ON THE CITY
MANAGER OF THE CITY WHERE
SACRAMENTO MOST OF THE CURRENT
CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT-
KHALLID- TODAY- I REPRESENTING
KHALLID TO BILLS SPONSORED BUT
ALSO NOTE THAT MY CITY WHAT
SACRAMENTO- IS ON RECORD AS
SUPPORTING SB SEVEN EIGHTY AND
WE'RE PROUD TO ALSO HAVE THE
FIRST THE IDEA IN THE STATE
OTHER WAS SET BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- THANKS TO
THE WORK OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE- FOR SEVERAL YEARS
CAL IT IS REPRESENTING MANY OF
ITS MEMBERS THAT ARE LOOKING
FOR NEW WAYS TO FINANCE
STRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS PUBLIC
FACILITIES. HOUSING PROJECTS
AND WE LED THE CHARGE TO BOTH
IMPLEMENT AND IMPROVE THE ID'S
AND CREUS- THIS BILL SB SEVEN
EIGHTY IT REPRESENTS THE NEXT
STEP IN IMPROVING BOTH OF THOSE
TOOLS- THAT ARE REALLY THE MOST
PROMISING TOOLS CALIFORNIA
CITIES HAVE FOR A PROJECT
FINANCING WITH THE OVERALL GOAL
OF INCREASING THE UTILIZATION
OF THE TOLL TO CROSS THE
STATE'S BEEN MENTIONED THAT
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED IN
AND- THE THESE TOOLS ARE REALLY
IN THEIR INFANCY AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL CITIES THAT THAT NOW
HOW THE IDEAS IN PLACE BUT WE
THINK THERE CAN BE. A QUITE A
FEW MORE- ONCE WE MAKE SOME OF
THESE- TECHNICAL IMPROVEMENTS I
HOPE YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE
THE FACT SHEET ABOUT THE BILL
PROVIDED BY THE AUTHOR IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE RELATIVELY MINOR
BUT REALLY IMPORTANT CHANGES
THAT THE BILL WOULD MAKE- SOME
OF THE CHANGES A UNIQUE THE
ID'S OTHER THE UNIQUE CREATORS-
BUT THE MOST SIGNIFICANT OF THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ACTUALLY APPLY
TO BOTH STATUTES AND I JUST
QUICKLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF THOSE- FIRST THE BILL
MAKES STREAMLINING IMPROVEMENTS
TO BOARD APPOINTMENTS FOR- FOR
BOTH TOOLS ALLOWING THE
APPOINTMENT OF ALTERNATE
MEMBERS AND ALSO SIMPLIFYING
THE BOARD OF STRUCTURE FOR
MULTIPLE- FOR EIGHTY THAT ARE
MADE UP OF MULTIPLE PUBLIC
AGENCIES. THAT'S ONE OF THE
PROMISING THINGS ABOUT
SPECIALLY ID'S A CITY A COUNTY
OTHER SPECIAL DISTRICTS CAN ALL
JOIN IN TO FINANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS SO THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PERMITS AND
SECOND- THE PROCESS FOR
AMENDING AN EXISTING PLAN HAS
ALSO BEEN- MENTIONED IN DOWN
THE ROAD YEARS NOW THAT'LL BE
AN IMPORTANT THING TO HAVE IN
PLACE WAS REALLY CONTEMPLATED
WHEN THE TOOLS ARE FIRST SET UP
I WAS WITH- IT'S AN IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR LATER BUT A LADY. AS I
SAID THERE ARE OTHER. PARTS OF
THE BILL TO MAKE TECHNICAL
MATTER CHANGE HIS- TO MAKE. THE
TO. AND MANAGE- THE BILL CAME
OUT OF A WORKING. OF PRACTICE.
OR BY K. IT HAD FOR SUPPORT AND
SENATE. I WANTED TO. THE
SENATOR- CORTESE FOR TAKING UP
THE ISSUE NOT FROM THE BILL.
ALSO ONE OF THE YOUR COMMITTEE.
CHAIR CONTINUE TAKE A STRONG
INTEREST IN THIS. VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIA. I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ROSE VERY MUCH MISTER
LAUREL WILL NOW HAVE MISTER
LANE. YOUR MEMBERS MICHAEL IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLAN
IN URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION.
A PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK
NANI'S BURKE. SAID THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES IN TWENTY ELEVEN ALL
OF US TO SPENT THE PAST DECADE
WORKING REPLACEMENT TOOLS. FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT CAN ALLOW
FOR BROWN TO REMEDIATION.
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
UPGRADES ASSEMBLAGE OF PARCELS.
AND PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE ARE WORKING THE IFT
IS CRAZY AS NIFTY IS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITIES.
IN ORDER TO RETAIN AT LEAST
SOME OF THE EFFICACY OF TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING PREVIOUSLY
AVAILABLE. PERSONALLY WHILE I
AM WORKING OF YOUR-
EXPLORATORIUM'S. USING TOOLS.
ONLY A HANDFUL OF PARTY. BUS
UNDERLINED THE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE AND PERFECT THESE
TOOLS. THAT WILL MAKE THE IFT
IS INCREASES MORE USER FRIENDLY
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE
NEED. RIGHT NOW TO ALLOWED TO
BE ADOPTED MORE WIDELY WE ARE
TONIGHT BOTH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ARE THERE ANY- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE IN THE AUDITORIUM I
DON'T SEE ANYONE LISTED SO I'M
GOING TO ASSUME WE'RE GOOD- DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON THE LINE
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND SLIME
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAT THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT FOR SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS FROM THE CAN BE
A LITTLE BOTH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOR ACTION FUNDS FOR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M FOR SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL I HAD. ABOUT YOUR
MEMBERS NECRO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CITY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ON THE
LINE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE. SAYING NONE I
BELIEVE I HAVE A HOME. A MOTION
BY BOERNER HORVATH IN A SECOND
BIASION MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU GIVENTHE BOTTOM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL- I WANT TO JUST SAY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
TOGETHER YEAH I'VE D. F. IDEAS
AND CREE IS- HAVE BEEN REALLY
SLOW TO GET THE CIGAR AND
THERE'S ONLY A FEW AND I MUST
COMMEND WEST SACRAMENTO THEY
WERE THE VERY FIRST ONE TO DO
THAT BUT- I BELIEVE YOUR-
CHANGES ARE MODEST CHANGES CAN
HELP MAKE THESE TOOLS TO BE
MORE. SUCCESSFUL FOR CITIES SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WILL
I WILL BE VOTING FOR THIS BILL
TODAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE ARE
CURRENTLY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
LACKEY. BLOOM HI WILL I AMMAR.
BOERNER HORVATH I LOS.
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT
RIVERSIDE REPEL REPEL HI. WE
HAVE SIX ZERO OKAY WE L. WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADAMS
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
CAN WELCOME MY WELCOME TO A- TO
THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU SO MUCH
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED YOU'RE
WELCOME NEXT WE'LL AVE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
SENATOR EGGMAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR HELLO FRIENDS HI
FRIENDS. SEE EVERYBODY MOVE THE
BILL WELL THERE YOU GO THAT'S
HOW I LIKE IT. ASSEMBLY WELCOME
BACK. THANK YOU THANK YOU THIS
IS A SIMPLE LITTLE BILL-
MEMBERS MEANT TO STAMP OUT
WATER THEFT YES RIGHT YOU MIGHT
BE SURPRISED PEOPLE STILL WATER
YES THEY DO THEY WILL HOOK UP
TO SOMEBODY'S HYDRANT HILLGROVE
WHAT BROUGHT THIS TO MY
ATTENTION- BECAUSE THE FINES
ARE REALLY LOW RIGHT NOW SO IF
YOU WOKE UP TO A HUNDRED SO
YOU'RE DOING A BIG CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT YOU LOOK UP. ILLEGALLY
YOU TAKE ALL THAT WATER FOR ALL
YOUR PROJECT. IF YOU CUSTOM ONE
HUNDRED DOLLAR FINE. THE CARD
AGAIN TO. THREE SO. WE'RE GOING
TO SAYTHAT THE FINE SHOULD BE
AT LEAST WHAT IT COSTS THE
PERMIT RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT
A THOUSAND DOLLARS I THINK IF
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH T GET
THE PERMIT. MAYBE WE COULD TALK
ABOUT LOWERING PERMITTING FEES
LATER. BUT IT IS THE WATER
DISTRICT'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
KEEP THAT CLEAN POTABLE WATER
IN PEOPLE HOOKING UP ILLEGALLY
TO BE ABLE TO RUN A BUSINESS.
IS NOT A GOOD USE OF PUBLIC
RESOURCES. AND WE KNOW WHAT THE
DROUGHT WE'RE GONNA BE HAVING
MORE OF THIS WATER THEFT. SO
THIS BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS. LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES WATER DISTRICTS
TO INCREASE THE FINES. IF IT'S
TOO MUCH FOR SOMEBODY WHO WAS
STOLEN WATER- DATE THAT THAT
THEY THERE IS A HARDSHIP PEOPLE
CAN APPLY FOR. WE THINK THAT
STRIKES A GOOD BALANCE OF
PRESERVING OUR WATER OF MAKING
SURE THAT THE PENALTIES MATCH
THE AT THAT THE CRIME. AND
MAKING SURE OUR MOST VALUABLE
RESOURCE WATER HE'S NOT THAT
USED IN VAIN. I HAVE TWO PEOPLE
WITH ME IN. SUPPORT RYAN-
JACKIE IN FROM THE REGIONAL
WATER AUTHORITY. AND BRUCE.
CAMILLUS FROM ELK GROVE WATER
DISTRICT. WELCOME THE BOTH ON
THE PHONE OPERATOR SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR- RYAN HAND OR BRUCE.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO HURT THEIR
LAST NAMES BECAUSE THEY'RE
DIFFICULT- JACKIE IN AND
PENNILESS. I STAFF PHONETICALLY
FOR ME YEAH. WHAT IT DIDN'T
GOOD ACTION CHAIRED MEMBERS OF
THE RYAN AND JACK IN GOD WE
MAILED MY NAME APPRECIATED THE
HARD ONE- GOOD WORK TO CENTER-
IGNORING STAFF ON ON GETTING
THAT RIGHT- AGAIN I'M WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY AND
RWAS JOINT POWERS THE TEACHING
COMPRISED OF TWENTY DRINKING
WATER SUPPLIERS THAT PROVIDE
WATER TO TWO MILLION PEOPLE OR
PEOPLE IN THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO AREA ARTICULATED
MISSION IS TO IMPROVE WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY AVAILABILITY
QUALITY AND AFFORDABILITY FOR
OUR MEMBERS AND THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY STERN. AND IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I THINK CENTER EGGMAN
NAILED ALL THE REASONS FOR WHY
WE- APPROACH- THE TENOR WITH
THE BILL AND- AGAIN I'LL
REITERATE THAT WE THINK THAT
THE BILL STRIKE THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE THAT MEETS ALL OF THOSE
GOALS THAT I JUST MENTIONED AND
FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS RWAS
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY ON AT THE FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN THANKS FOR THE
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND.
WILL NOW HAVE BRUCE CAMILLUS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU-
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
MY NAME IS BRUCE CAMILLUS AND I
AM THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
OAK GROVE WATER DISTRICT. WHICH
SUPPLIES DRINKING WATER TO
FORTY SIX THOUSAND CUSTOMERS IN
ELK GROVE. EVERY YEAR WE HAVE
CONTRACTORS A LEGALLY CONNECT
TO OUR WATER SYSTEM TO STILL
WATER FOR THEIR PROJECTS. THESE
INCIDENTS POSE A SERIOUS THREAT
TO PEOPLE'S HEALTH AND
CONTAMINATION OF A WATER SYSTEM
CAN OCCUR WHEN DIRTY EQUIPMENT
IS A LEGALLY HOOKED UP. TO A
FIRE HYDRANT CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR PENALTIES
SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE A
DETERRENT. AND WATER AGENCIES
NEED THE AUTHORITY TO INCREASE
FINES TO DETER WATER THEFT AND
KEEP OUR WATER SAFE AND CLEAN.
WE BELIEVE SENATE BILL FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN WE'LL DO THAT AND
I LIKE TO THINK SENATOR EGGMAN
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL AND I
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL FOUR TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. NONE OTHER. ON THE- HELLO
I'M HERE BECAUSE OF FOR A LOT
MUSIC THIS YEAR NAME BECAUSE-
ON THE BILL. OPERATOR THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR TO SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR TO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. HOWEVER COMMA YES.
YEAH I WOULD WANT TO SAY FIRST
OF ALL THAT- IN MY DISTRICT WE
HAVE A UNIQUE A PROBLEM WITH
WATER THEFT. AND IT'S REALISTIC-
PEOPLE. AND THEY ARE STEALING
MILLIONS OF GALLONS OF WATER SO
I WISH THIS BILL WOULD FURTHER.
BUT THAT'S RIGHT COMING FROM
THIS IS A REAL SERIOUS PROBLEM
IN THE DESERT WE HAVE WATER
ISSUES ANYWAYS. AND THESE
PEOPLE. ARE WITHOUT FEAR AND
THEY ARE REALLY REALLY AND
POSING A PROBLEM FOR US IN OUR
REGION SO THANK YOU FOR THIS.
ANYONE ELSE HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION. OKAY SEEING NONE WE
HAVE A MOTION BY
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
IS THERE A SECOND DIDN'T OF.
OKAY SKEWS ME I DIDN'T HEAR YOU
MISTER RIVAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS SECOND THE BILL. HOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. IT IS
LOVELY TO SEE ALL OF YOU AND
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WELL
THAT'S GOOD I'M GLAD YOU LIKE
TO SEE THIS- SO HERE WE GO WITH
ANOTHER TOUGH DROUGHT IN ITS
REPORT THAT EVERYONE IS WORKING
TOGETHER TO CONSERVE ON WATER
RESOURCES I'M SUPPORTING A BILL
TODAY THANK YOU FOR BEING A
FORWARD. AND MOTIONS TO PASS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
ADD LACKEY HI. WELL I'VE-
BOERNER HORVATH I ROMMEL'S
THREE OF US THREE OF US AYE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I'VE
A PAL. HI WE HAVE SEVEN ZERO
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH BILLS
THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR. ROSES
ARE RED HAT WILL HOLD THE- THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADD ONS ON THE
BILL. OKAY WELL WE HAVE A
WAITING FOR DOCTOR WHAT DO WE
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. TEN
FLOOR MAKE ENTERTAINING MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
EXCUSE ME ALREADY READ THE
ITEMS IS HIS NAME. SB EIGHT TEN
GOVERNORS AND FINANCED OR
VALIDATIONS. SB ELEVEN
GOVERNORS OF FINANCE CAN THIS
BE A TWELVE THERE WERE SOME
FINANCE. AND S. B. FOUR THREE
B. EIGHT LAYERED. AND S. BEFORE
THIRTY ONE RUBIO. SB SEVENTY
NINE EXCUSE ME THOSE ALL ON
OUR CONSENT AND WE HAVE A
MOTION. BYE I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FOR THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
ROBERT MUELLER'S. FOLLOW YES
AGUIAR-CURRY RIGHT. ALL RIGHT
MACKEY I'M LUCKY I BLOOM. HELLO
FIVE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I'M RAMOS.
THREE OF US THREE OF US AYE
ROBERT RIVAS NUMBER RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL WELL I SEVEN ZERO. OKAY
LOOKS LIKE WE ARE LOOKING FOR
AN AUTHOR I'M LOOKING FOR-
SENATOR GLAZERS. FOR LET'S SEE
LOOKS LIKE CENTRO. CRISPR WHITE
HOUSE HE. THOSE FOR YOUR CAN WE
DO ADD ONS- SECRETARY CARRIED
OUT ON FOR WE HAVE A CHANCE
WITH ONE- IN MY WE GOT WE GOT
AUTHOR. YEAH AMONG OTHER. OKAY
THIS IS ITEM. LET'S SEE HERE
NUMBER. ELEVEN I KNOW YOUR LOVE
AND I'M SORRY. I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
AWAY WE DON'T KNOW OKAY. OKAY
WELCOME SENATORS BURKE. MOVE
THE BILL. HAS FOR NINE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE MAKING THEM.
THEY'RE PROBABLY GET RIGHT I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN
YES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES
AND FROM THE CALIFORNIA COAST
KEEPERS ALLIANCE SURE. YEAH
**** THE CONCISE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR JESSICA AND OR CAITLIN. AND
OPERATOR WE OPEN THE LINE FOR
THOSE TWO WOMEN. JUST CLICK
GAUGER. RIVAS IN REVERSE MY
GIRLFRIEND OKAY THIS IS SB TWO
SEVEN THREE. YOU CAN BEGIN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M JEFF
CARTOGRAPHY CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES
HERE THE CROWD COSPONSORED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
GIVEN THE LATE HOUR AND
PROMOTION I WILL JUST OFFERED
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND I WOULD
URGE- I THOUGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE LOVE YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH K. IS CAITLYN AVAILABLE.
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEPERS I
GUESS GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AYE HE
WILL FOLLOW- ARE COKE BONTA IS
LEAD AND OF MYSELF ON THE
QUALITY MANAGER FOR CALIFORNIA
COULD BE PER LINE WE ARE CLIP
ONS ARE SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY
THREE ALONGSIDE THE CALIFORNIA
SITUATION IT'S ANTI AGING
SEVENTIES AGENCIES. OVERALL WE
URGE YOUR COMMITTEE AYE VOTES
OF SP TWO SEVENTY THREE TO
REMOVE EXISTING BARRIERS FOR
INNOVATIVE. CAPTURE ENTRY
STORMWATER THAT RUNS OUT FOR
THREE SEVERAL IMPROVE WATER
QUALITY COURAGE LOCAL WATER
RECYCLING AND ULTIMATELY HELP
CALIFORNIA AUGMENT ITS WATER
SUPPLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BEFORE GOING FURTHER
THIS- YOU HAVE AN AMENDMENT SO
DUE TO DATA ABOUT THIS I DON'T
DRIVE AND I REMEMBER I. AM A
PROJECTING THE MEMBER THREE.
THEY OFFICE WANTS TO DO A
MEMBER ON MY OLD BILL ON THE-
S. B. TWO THIRTY ONE ON. ON THE
SALINAS CASE I'M NOT ACCEPTING.
SOMEONE WORKING ON THAT
AMENDMENT THERE SORRY. OKAY
WELL THEN WE. HOLD ON SIR WE
HAVE AND WE HAVE YOU AS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT WILL I MEAN
JUST VERIFY IT'S CALAVERAS FELL
OFF GO HAS A QUESTION ON
AMENDMENTS. CAN YOU GIVE ME A
MINUTE SIR BECAUSE LIKE TO
COURSE OF COURSE GET THIS
THROUGH WITHOUT HAVING THE
AMENDMENT ON THERE FOR. YEAH
WHAT I OPEN THE PHONE LINES
WILL BE READ OKAY OKAY ALL
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON THE
LINE YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
PLEASE THIS IS FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THAT SPEED TWO
SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOUR LINES
IN QUEUE LINES FOR SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BASS- ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE SIX NINE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ANTHONY CANNON NOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU I'M SORRY. WE
CAN THANK YOU RIGHT FOR SEVENTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON JULIE HALL
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU TO COMPLETE
THE FOLLOWING. YOU'RE RIGHT
CHAU TO THIS. IF YOU MATTER
MEMBERS COMMITTEE BARGAINS ALL
THIS ON BEHALF CARRY WATER
DISTRICT IS A HOAX AND
ROOSEVELT. THE RESEARCH THANK
YOU. I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE I'M NOW
LOOKING FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT'S FINE RELIGION
S. B. TWO SEVEN THREE. MEMBERS
REJECTED. THIS WITH YOUR
DEALERSHIP. THAT ACTUALLY. ONE
AT THE END AFTER TIME. THAT'S A
GOOD AGO. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. OKAY YES-
SKEWS ME ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
IN OTHER OR NOT. I HAVE COUNSEL.
THERE'S TWO SETS OF AMENDMENTS
THE FIRST SET OF IN THEM SO THE
ONES THAT WE HAVE ADOPTED AND A
CITY DOES THE SECOND WAS THAT
THERE WAS A PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
BUT I WANTED O REJECT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT IS PRESENTED TO ME I
ACCEPT THOSE MA'AM AND SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR-
INSIGHTFUL GUIDANCE ON THAT.
WELL THAT'S GOOD SO THE MOTION
OKAY SO IS THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OTHER THAN IN A
COMPLETE GOOD LUCK WITH IT SEE
WHAT WE HAVE YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION. MOTION IS BEHIND HIM
BOERNER HORVATH AND SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM I
BELIEVE. OKAY THANK YOU OKAY
WHICH I TO CLOSE THEIR
OPPOSITION. CAN YOU HAVE NONE
YOU SURE THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
AND DECLARE SALT OKAY GOOD
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN OPPOSITION
LETTER BUT AS LONG AS NOBODY
ONLINE IT'S GOOD YES I JUST AS
FROM A VOTERS REALLY APPRECIATE
THE- EXPEDITIOUS NATURE OF THIS
VETERANS JUST YOU KNOW LOOK
WATER SUCH IMPORTANT ISSUE FROM
ALL CORNERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THESE THINGS ON THE SURFACE IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A BIG DEAL
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO-
BREAK DOWN THE BARRIERS AMONG
WATER AGENCIES AND SANITATION
DISTRICTS TO ALLOW THEM TO
VOLUNTARILY COOPERATE TO
INCLUDE AMONG THE REPERTOIRE OF
DEALING WITH CONSERVATION
SUSTAINABILITY THE ISSUE OF
STORMWATER S. RIVAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SO YEAH I'M JUST
ASKING THE OPPOSITION LETTERS
FROM YEAH THE HOWARD JARVIS.
WHILE HE PERSON HE SAID TO ME.
HE I KNOW HE DIDN'T HE'S DEAD.
WHAT IS IT FOR MY DEATH IS A
VERY CONNECT OKAY. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T- BIG KNOWLEDGE TO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH CAL LEFT OR EVEN
IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT YOU DID
ON THE AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL.
YOU MEAN THE KNOX CORTESE HURTS
BUT I GOT TO. FOUR YEARS AN
ATTACK AND I KNOW YOU DID. WELL
WITH THOSE WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL THE DATE THE MARSHES
DO PASSES A MINUTE TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
IRAQI. LACKEY ALBUM. LOU I'M
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I'M RAMOS.
THREE OF US THREE OF US ARE
ROBERT RIVAS. WEBER RIVERSIDE
REPEL. REPEL. HI WE HAVE SEVEN
ZERO. SEVEN ZERO. THEY WERE
MISSING THEY DON'T REALLY HAVE
AN INTEREST SOMEONE WILL THE
ROLE OPEN I DON'T THINK THAT'S
GROSS HEY HOW'S THE BEST OF US.
OKAY THE NEXT STEP IS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB SIXTY EIGHT US
SENATOR GLAZERS. MOST OF THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BRING ME
HAVE A SECOND RAMOS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LUCKY. AND I WILL BE
BRIEF- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THIS BILL IS
SIMILAR TO A BILL LAST YEAR
THAT YOU PASSED SB TEN FORTY
NINE. PASSED BOTH HOUSES BY A
WIDE MARGIN BUT A FORCE THAT WE
RAN OUT OF TIME FOR CONCURRENCE
I WOULD ALLOW THE CITY OR
COUNTY- IMPOSE A FINE OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER VIOLATION
OF A SHORT TERM RENTAL.
ORDINANCE GIVES US CITIES AND
COUNTIES A LITTLE ADDITIONAL
POWER TO TRY TO REGULATE THIS
INDUSTRY AND- WITH ME TODAY A
COUPLE FOLKS TO TESTIFY ORINDA
MAYOR AMY WORTH AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE SPEEDY-
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OPERATOR
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AMY WORTH.
AND ALISON IN FUN. ALL RIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON GIRLFRIEND ALL
RIGHT YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS AMY WORSE
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
SIXTY CENTS IT'S LATE THIS
AFTERNOON I'M GOING TO. KEEP MY-
REMARKS VERY BRIEF- BUT I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY AND- YOU ALL RECALL
THE TRAGIC MURDERS ON HALLOWEEN
NIGHT AND ARRAIGNED AT THAT
OCCURRED. AT AN ILLEGAL
GATHERING AT A SHORT TERM
RENTAL IN THIS UNSPEAKABLE
TRAGEDY WAS DEVASTATING TO THE
FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS. AND TO
OUR COMMUNITY SO WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO SENATOR GLAZERS FOR
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION
WHICH- WOULD PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
TOOLS FOR CITIES TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE AND ENFORCE.
THEIR SHORT TERM RENTAL
ORDINANCES SO I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
SB SIXTY AND ALSO FOR YOUR
IMPORTANT WORK ON BEHALF OF.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
SPEAKER AND THAT'S- THE STENSON.
IT'S A REPRESENT OF AN XPS HI
OKAY. HELLO SO IT WILL AFFECT
HI. THANK YOU MATTER MANY
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
BUILT THE FENCE AND I HAVE THE
HONOR OF SERVING AS EXPEDIA
GROUP'S REGIONAL GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR CALIFORNIA.
EXPEDIA GROUP THAT THE FAMILY
HAS TRAVEL BRANDS INCLUDING
VACATION RENTAL LEADER VERBO.
WE ARE PROUD TO WORK WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
SUPPORT BALANCE AND SHORT TERM
RENTAL REGULATION- BALLOT ARE
CORRECT THE REGULATIONS THAT
MEET THE NEEDS THAT. YOU
COMMUNITY AND WE'RE PROUD TO BE
PART OF SENATE BILL SIXTY I
THINK SIXTEEN IS AN IMPORTANT
EFFORTS YOU GET. TOLD AT I DO
THINK ABOUT HOW THAT REGULATE
SHORT TERM RENTALS. SACRAMENTO
IN AND ENFORCE THOSE WHICH FIND
FOR THE BAD ACTORS. IT'S TO
THINK SENATOR GLAZERS BROKEN.
HAVE ON THAT ISSUE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
MOVING THAT FORWARD THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THERE'S NONE IN THE
AUDITORIUM. ARE THERE ANY ON
THE PHONE. OKAY I DON'T HAVE
ANY ON RECORD THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE SPEAKERS SO WHEN WE
TAKE THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT CHIU FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
NOT YOUR MOMMA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL
AND LODGING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE FOR SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIRED MEMBERS
EVEN MONEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FRANK FOR SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MAYOR- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WERE GONNA
CARPACCIO ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BECAUSE IT
TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE AND CORK. THANK YOU.
RIGHT FOR SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GRAB. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHNNY PINA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CITY THAN BEFORE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION NAME-
ORGANIZATIONS. POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WE HAVE
A MOTION I BELIEVE LET'S SEE WE
HAVE A MOTION BY- BRUNNER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURNER FOR FAR.
THIS IS HARD. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY IS THE SECOND-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
MY CO AUTHOR ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BOERNER HORVATH AND AS WELL AS
A FAMILY WOMAN- REBEKAH BAUR
QUE HAN. AND THANK THEM FOR
THEIR SUPPORT AND- APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- I SUPPORT YOUR
BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS A GOOD
BILL I'M PLEASED TO DO IT AGAIN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO IMPOSE EFFECTIVE FIND SOME
BAD ACTORS WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE SHORT TERM RENTAL MARKET
ESPECIALLY REPEAT OFFENDERS AND
THOSE WHO ENDANGER OUR
NEIGHBORS AND OTHERS. SO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY NINE AGUIAR-CURRY
I LACKEY I'M LUCKY I BLEW. WILL
BOERNER HORVATH. I RIVALS
THREE OF US THREE OF US AYE
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER RIVERSIDE.
VOEPEL ALL RIGHT SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER AND%
HOLD THE ROLE FOR ADAMS HAVE A
GREAT AFTERNOON- WE ARE LOOKING
FOR US SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
IN THE MEANTIME WHAT DO WE DO
THE ITEMS THAT WE CAN DO IS
THAT OKAY SECRETARY. OKAY. SB
THREE TWENTY THREE. CAVALEIRO
SHE WAS THE DO PASSED TO DO
THIS THE BILL CURRENTLY IS
SEVEN ZERO LACKEY I FLAT FEE
ALL RIGHT THE VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO BILL AND STUFF. SB SEVEN
EIGHTEEN CORTESE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE HOUSE AND THEY CAN
BE A DEVELOPMENT. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ZERO. BLACKIE I
BLACKIE AYE RAMOS. THE LOTUS
SEVEN ZERO AND WAIT FOR HIS
PHONE. SB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
EGGMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR THE CURRENT LOTUS
SEVEN ZERO RAMOS. STILL. SEVEN
ZERO. NORWAY'S CALENDAR. RAMOS
OKAY. THAT'S IT ALL RIGHT YEAH.
RAMOS OKAY WHY DON'T WE- WE
MADE A CALL FROM SERGEANTS TO
CENTER WHITE HOUSE HIS OFFICE.
ON.
ALL.
THIS YEAH. YEAH IF
YOU'RE NOT DOING. LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE PROGRAM. WELL MAYBE
OKAY
- YEAH. ALMOST. YEAH. BURKE
WHATEVER. RIGHT A LITTLE. THE
PHARMACY. YEAH. YEAH RIGHT HERE.
ALL OF. RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT ALL
OF THE WONDERFUL AND LEARN MORE.
IN ORDER. YEAH THE IS A ARE YOU
ARE YOU BOB. SO LONG. OKAY YEAH.
BOB FROM. ONE- RIGHT- HARPER-
HI EVERYBODY. WALDRON. THE
WORKING. YEAH. YEAH. RIGHT YEAH
ALL.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY CORTESE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THE VOTERS
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO RAMOS
RAMOS I THE VOTE IS DOWN. EIGHT
ZERO. SB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
EGGMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO RAMOS RAMOS I. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO RAMOS
RAMOS I. THAT. EIGHT SB TWO
SEVEN THREE HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS THE VOTERS CURRENTLY
SEVEN ZERO RAMOS RAMOS I AT
VOTERS. EIGHT ZERO- SB SIXTY
GLAZER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH THE FLOOR. THE CARD
VOTER SEVEN ZERO RAMOS RAMOS
ALL RIGHT THAT'S EIGHT ZERO.
THAT'S IT. AT THE. WE'RE GOOD-
WE'RE GOOD. PERFECT. ONE LAST
CALL FOR SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI.
S. B. TWO SEVEN FOUR WE
WILL MOVE OVER TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE MEETING
THE FOLLOWING MEETING WHICH I
BELIEVE IS ON. WHICH IS THE
TWENTY THIRD OF JUNE SO WE'LL
MOVE. S. B. TWO SEVEN FOUR ITEM
FIFTEEN OVER TO OUR NEXT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. AND I
THINK WE HAVE EVERYTHING TAKEN
CARE OF SO THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL. YEAH
WITH.